.
So.
Ich muss gerade nochmal ein Brötchen fertig essen.
Ja, moin Philips, ich hab gesehen du bist schon ein bisschen da.
Was soll das hier eigentlich für ein bescheuertes Vergleich sein?
Warum soll ich in irgendeiner Form irgendwelche FPS Unterschiede haben zwischen der NVMe und der Asata?
Zumindest bei so einer Benchmark Geschichte, das ist totaler Blödsinn.
Vielleicht mal irgendwo wenn es scheiße programmiert ist ein paar Slowdowns, weil es nicht richtig rein streamt, aber...
Phil, was wollen die uns damit sagen?
Ach nee, das ist das Intro, wie schnell das lädt, oder?
Hä?
Okay, das sind Ladezeiten, ja das macht Sinn. Ladezeiten macht Sinn, das leuchtet mir noch ein.
Das passt noch.
Aber ich hab schon Videos gesehen, ich dachte das wäre eins davon, wo sie quasi gesagt haben,
SSD versus, äh, M2 SSD versus Asata SSD versus irgendwas, und dann haben sie irgendwelche Benchmarks im Kreis laufen lassen.
Das ist doch vollkommen wurscht und dann macht der Platten, äh, was die Platten I.O. jetzt so wirklich kaum unterschied.
Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung von Unreal 4 und auch keine Ahnung von Unity.
Aber ich sag euch, ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich mit Unity auch ein billig Battle Royale Game mit Sachen aus dem Asset Store zusammenwursten könnte.
Ich sag mal Unity, weil Unity ist C-Sharp und Unreal ist entweder Blueprint klicken oder C++.
Oder kann man mittlerweile auch C-Sharp in Unreal verwenden, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Kannst du Responsive Web Design?
Was verstehst du unter Responsive Web Design?
Also ich weiß, ich weiß was es ist, aber ich will, ich will erstmal wissen, was du für einer verstehst, dann kann ich dir auch sagen, ob ich, ob ich das kann oder nicht.
Gar nichts.
Okay.
Also möchtest du wissen, was Responsive Web Design ist?
Was mit Responsive Web Design gemeint ist, ist eigentlich hauptsächlich, dass die Webseite sich an die Größe von einem Display anpasst.
Also zum Beispiel das hier ist Responsive Web Design.
Dass hier das Menü sichtbar ist und wenn der Bildschirm kleiner wird oder die Zoomstufe höher wird, das Menü ausgeblendet wird und auch die Buttons da sind.
Das ist zum Beispiel Responsive Web Design.
Du brauchst Hilfe beim Programmieren.
Das heißt, du brauchst Hilfe, was C-S-S angeht wahrscheinlich.
Okay, C-S-S.
Lad mal bei Pastebin hoch und schickt mal, vielleicht können wir uns das angucken.
Ich weiß, dass wir hier im Chat einige C-S-S-Pros haben, die sich auskennen.
Ich bin jetzt nicht so der übelste C-S-S-Kenner.
Aber mach mal Pastebin.
So, reloaden wir das mal, ob da irgendwas gescheites vorgeschlagen wird.
Das haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
Das ist definitiv kein echter Gameboy.
Wenn ich ja schon Gameboy sehe mit sechs Buttons.
Da stimmt schon etwas.
Mit sechs Buttons und einem Analogstick.
Seems legit.
Google Reduction with Lego Gears.
Was macht der Typ?
Das dauert nicht so lange.
Da kann ich wunderbar mein Brötchen noch dabei essen.
Was macht der Typ?
Ah, yes. Natürlich. Was auch sonst.
Ich weiß, dass Google oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, das ist eine sehr große Zahl.
Das ist, was weiß ich, 10 hoch 3 Spiliaren.
Keine Ahnung. 10 hoch 100, okay.
1 hoch 100, okay.
1 hoch 100 ergibt keinen Sinn. 1 hoch 100 ist 1. Es müssen 10 hoch 100 sein.
Okay, ich ahne Schlimmes.
Ich ahne Schlimmes. Das wird jetzt ein Riesending mit immer weiteren Gears.
Ist ja nur die Frage, ob sein Tisch ausreicht.
Oh, jetzt wird es advanced hier.
Das ist quasi ein riesig langes Pause-Champ-Video.
Weil es immer langsamer wird.
Okay, ich muss mal ein bisschen vorspulen.
Der baut diese eine Call of Duty Map mit dem Riesenrad nach.
Ich hau mir noch schnell mein Brötchen rein.
Streamst du auch am Dienstagmorgen? Wieso, was ist da? Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Ist da irgendwie Apple Event oder so?
Also ansonsten nicht.
Nee, Dienstag bin ich arbeiten.
Wtf?
Excellent.
Korgas.
Was gibt denn das, wenn es falsch ist?
Bewegt sich das am Ende überhaupt noch?
Dieses Ding hat ja auch einen gewissen Widerstand, dass es sich dreht.
Wobei, die Übersetzung ist so hoch, dass es sich klar dreht.
Es dreht sich wahrscheinlich so langsam, dass man sein Leben davor setzen muss,
dass man auch nur ein Zahnrad sieht oder so.
Ach du Scheiße.
Wie gesagt, ich futter noch schnell mein Brötchen, deswegen habe ich das Headset auf dem Kopf und nicht hier am Mund.
Weil wir machen heute keine ASMR-Eatings aus.
Aber der will es echt wissen.
Ich glaube, der einzige Grund, warum man das macht, ist weil es geht.
Aber das hat, glaube ich, keinen tieferen Sinn.
Ich glaube, bis das einmal eine Umdrehung am Ende gemacht hat, ist der Lego-Motor kaputt.
Und je nachdem, ich kann es schlecht abschätzen, wie lange das am Ende wirklich dauert.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich meine, es ist 10 Uhr 100.
Das ist eine Zahl mit 100 Nullen.
Das ist ganz schön viel.
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird theoretisch bis zum Ende des Sonnensystems brauchen oder noch länger,
bis es sich einmal umgedreht hat.
Hast du schon die Cod Beta eingespielt?
Ja, ich habe gestern, glaube, um die 5 Stunden gespielt und vorgestern auch schon ein bisschen.
Ist hier der Lego-Hacker-Man hier?
Ich hätte nicht gesagt gleich was zu dem, was ihr gefragt habt, wenn ich fertig gegessen habe.
Hat jemals schon mal jemand so einen Teil gesehen?
Was ist das überhaupt?
Ich habe auch das hier, ich habe das Lego-Teil noch nie gesehen.
Das finde ich auch.
Ja, bis zum Ende des Sonnensystems kommt hin und das ist aber noch deutlich länger.
Wenn man sich überlegt, das Universum ist ja NUR in Anführungsstrichen irgendwie 14
Milliarden Jahre alt, ungefähr. Das sind also ein Vielfaches vom Alter des Universums hier.
Ok, das hat er einfach gebaut, weil es geht. Coole Idee, zwar komplett useless, aber coole
Idee. Die krassen Effects hier drüber gemacht.
Wollt ihr sich jetzt damit mit seinem Vegas-Filter austoben? Ich Coggers.
Also das ist wirklich bei Coggers im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und dann stellt sich raus,
er hat eine Schraube vergessen. Ja, er hätte ja schon mal ein bisschen warten können mit
dem Video aufnehmen, dass er so einen Zeitraffer macht, oder?
Gibt es Coggers eigentlich auch anders trennt? Also nicht bei mir, man kann das Gift bestimmt
spiegeln. Cooles Teil. Komplett sinnlos, aber nice.
Das ist quasi Coggers in Person. Ihh, Excel. So, kurz Musik wieder anmachen.
So Leute, ich bin fertig futtern. Gut, jetzt können wir loslegen. Also mit was, mit was?
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mal ein bisschen mit Battlefield oder so an. Wo habe ich den
Battlefield auf? Ihh, was soll dieses Pop-Up immer? EFOT? Battlefield 3 Clips, exellent.
Kann ich mich wieder drüber lustig machen, dass die Gegner absolut braindead sind. 7.
Oktober, haben wir das schon geguckt? Wann ist 7. Oktober? Letzte Woche, das haben wir
bestimmt schon geguckt. Haben wir letzte Woche Battlefield 3 geguckt? Ich glaube, das
kennen wir schon, oder? Alter, die sind schon wieder so richtig braindead, die Gegner. Obbei,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das gesehen haben. Das kommt mir jetzt gar nicht so bekannt
vor. Schauen wir mal. Also, ich mache den Typ absichtlich nicht so laut, ähm, weil
der eh immer das Gleiche sagt. Nice Headshot. Hier in der Modern Warfare Beta,
na quatsch nicht in der Modern Warfare Beta, in der Cold War Beta. Es ist ja echt so, dass
du wieder nur krasse Leute am Start hast. Also davon war ja auszugehen, aber es ist
so heftig. Es geht keiner mit einer KD über 2 raus. Ganz selten mal. Also, es ist eigentlich
total ätzend, weil du permanent 100% spielen musst wieder. Das nervt. Ohne Ende. Ich meine,
wenn man das in irgendeinem Ranking drin hat, ok. Aber doch nicht, wenn ich mich einfach
für Quickplay cue. Außerdem sind zwei von den 5 Maps in der Beta schon abgrundtief nervig.
Nämlich Miami und Cartel. Der Rest geht halbwegs. Aber gerade Cartel ist total kackmap.
Moment, zeig euch mal, ja genau, das ist die Map hier. Also, die haben sich gedacht, ok,
wir machen einfach eine offene Map mit Büschen und du siehst keine Gegner. Man sieht allgemein
relativ schwierig Gegner, aber das ist bestimmt eine Gewöhnungssache. Aber auf Cartel, du
siehst einfach keine Gegner und wirst komplett random von irgendwo erschossen. Ich meine,
es ist ja schon ein bisschen Markenzeichen von Call of Duty random erschossen werden,
aber hier ist es wirklich ganz extrem. Ja, wir gucken erst mal noch in Battlefield. Als
die Games etwas getaugt haben. Ah, vorbei. Entschreckt. Es ist nicht ganz so schlimm
wie in Modern Warfare die Maps. Unexpected Clips. Schon wieder. Moment, den Typ hatten
wir jetzt schon so oft. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das immer der gleiche Clip ist oder ob
man einfach nur der Einzige ist mit Webcam. Ok, das war nice. Erstmal wegdefibrilliert.
What? Was? Was? Ja, Exe hoffe ich auch. Ich habe aber da keine Großart. What? Der
wird vom Mörser in Arsch geblastet. Ich wusste ehrlich gesagt gar nicht in Battlefield 3,
dass die Mörser wirklich fliegen. Ich dachte immer, das ist so eine Sache, die tun so.
Also die brechen einfach wie das fliegen würde und lassen sie dann einschlagen. Ich wusste
gar nicht, dass Mörser in Battlefield 3 wirklich fliegen. Michael, 5 Billionen, 10 Monate. Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription. Ok, Gunship war bescheuert. Das hat sich überhaupt nicht gut eingefügt
in Battlefield 3. Nice. So weit nach einem Hyper-Subscriber. Nice. Wie viele Granatenschrott-Kills.
Gut, schöner Treppenflank, das geht immer gut. Muss es echt wieder M16 sein? Oh, es
gibt kaum, es gibt kaum, also Null ist wirklich die Grenze. Also Null ist quasi ins Game einloggen
und sich nicht bewegen. Das ist wirklich das Schlechteste, was möglich ist, wie Gegner
sind. Also es gibt eigentlich kaum was, wo es nicht noch schlechter geht. Ich habe leiser
gemacht. Ich meine, von rechts nach links ist es leiser. Die sind nicht schlecht, die
sind afk. Ne, die sind tatsächlich nicht afk. Die sind einfach nur dumm. Alter, die
sacken ja hardcore. Ah, Shotgun. Übrigens, die SPAS-12 ist in Cold War, ist ein secondary
Auto-Shotgun. Ich weiß, also was da mit Treyarch wieder los ist. Secondary Auto-Shotgun, exzellent.
Oh, nice. Die Gegner waren diesmal gar nicht so wirklich blöd, aber du kannst ja da nichts
dagegen machen. Der Typ hätte als Rätsel ihn halt killen müssen, aber er hat sich nicht
um die Ecke getraut. Oh, das ist ja immer geil. C4-Droppen und dann BÄÄM. Achtung,
Banate. Hä? Okay, alle Glück gehabt. Moin. Schon wieder er. Ja, und da erkennste, die
Pros, da werden Callouts verwendet. Mittel und dann geht der Office und so, das ist ja
schon hier. Exzellent. Ganz ehrlich, ich wüsste nur nicht mal mehr ansatzweise irgendwelche
Callouts für Battlefield 3, sofern ich sie je wusste. Wobei Callouts, zwar ganz im Ernst,
wenn man alleine ist, ist ja wurscht, aber im Team, es gibt fast nichts Wichtigeres, mit
was man anfangen sollte, als mit Callouts zu lernen. Und nach Möglichkeit die Callouts,
die alle verwenden. Also es hat keinen Sinn, wenn jetzt irgendwie was auf Englisch Shop
heißt und ihr sagt auf Deutsch immer Dönerbude oder so. Das ist wie in CS. In CS gibt's
auch auf der einen Map was, wo die Deutschen immer Mini-Döner zu sagen. Weißt das nicht,
auf Mirage oder so, Mini-Döner, war das nicht? Was halt Internationaler keine Sau versteht.
Zumindest Callouts ist echt eines der wichtigsten Sachen, die es gibt. Weil ich glaube jeder
kennt das, er spielt mit Leuten und, keine Ahnung, ein Gegner ist am Start und da gibt's
dann so geile Ansagen wie, rechts an der Wand. Und dann denkt sich der andere, was? Rechts?
Wand? Welche Wand und welches rechts? Ich guck in die ganz andere Richtung. Also links-rechts-Ansagen,
wenn man im Team spielt, ist es meistens ziemlich schwammig. Also Callouts ist echt, der spielt
jetzt allein, ist egal, aber das hab ich bisher in allen Games, wo man einfach mit Leuten
spielt. Callouts ist das A und O. Und noch mehr Webcams. Die Battlefield 3 Leute werden
langsam, langsam kommen die im Jahr 2020, aber die haben alle Webcams hier. Battlefield
3 wird ja noch richtig hier professionell. Ja hinter dir ist auch geil. Da weißt du sofort
ab, Scheiß. Oh nice. Alter, wie die sich wieder wegsprayen lassen.
Macht's jetzt gleich. Oder auch nicht. Ah, nee. Er springt raus und 720 zieht sich erstmal
ein ab. Und trifft zufällig den Panzer. Leute, also diese Clips, so cool die sind, ja, so
cool die sind, predicted ist da nix. Der hat grob in die Richtung geschossen, der Typ ist
halt reingefahren. Oder noch nicht mal reingefahren, reingelaufen. Brrrrt. Ist bitte der gleiche
Typ? Oh, oh, oh. Bam. Nice. Easy clap. Ich weiß nicht ob ich ein Video zur Call vormache.
Also ich hab gar nicht vor, noch großartig zu spielen. Jetzt. Ich hab gestern 5 Stunden
gespielt und davor irgendwie noch mal 2. Eigentlich reicht's mir schon wieder. Es ist halt das
was ich vermutet hab, es ist, es fühlt sich an wie ein Reskin von Modern Warfare. Wo sie
ein paar Sachen entfernen und ein paar Sachen hinzu gemacht haben. Und es spielt sich fast,
fast genauso. Nicht ganz so extrem rum gesitze, aber es spielt sich sehr ähnlich. Da legt
einer. Geiler Schneiberdude, äh. Messern. Was ist mit die, was, was ist mit den Gegnern
los? Das ist ja PP-Gaim hoch 3. Wenn die G18 ist OP auf die Range. Aber guckt euch mal
den Dude an, der trifft nicht einmal. Ok, der wenigstens. Also manche Sachen kann ich
nicht mehr ganz anvollziehen. Und ich treff schon richtig schlecht, ne. Also ich hab jetzt
ja wieder ein halbes Jahr oder so schon wieder her seit ich Warzone gespielt hab. Und gestern
und vorgestern ich hab Anfälle gekriegt am Anfang. Ich hab erst mal wieder gnadenlos
über-aimed, unter-aimed, sonst was. So keine Ahnung, hier ist der Gegner, so nach dem Motto
oder sag mal so, hier ist der Gegner, hab ich erst mal so gemacht, dann hab ich so gemacht,
dann hab ich so gemacht, dann hab ich so gemacht. Ah ok, ich hab dich getroffen. Ja, jetzt
geht's mittlerweile wieder. Es ist immer so, wenn man der Weile nix gespielt hat, aber
irgendwann kommt er relativ schnell wieder drauf. Nice. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt
an? Da war grad ein Battlefield. Why I still use Windows? Ok, das ist bestimmt ein Schwachsinnensvideo.
Ach, es gibt übrigens ein neues Windows. Windows, irgendwie hat da einer ein Video
zugemacht. Wer wurde denn? Hier, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, die Windows-October-Update-Neuerung.
Von denen haben wir uns schon ein paar Sachen eingeguckt und ich hab mich auch schon ein
paar Mal über so Tuning-Tipps lustig gemacht in so Videos. Ok, mal gucken, was Microsoft
jetzt wieder für Wahnsinnsänderungen rausgehauen hat im neuesten Windows-Update. Ich predikte
mal ein paar Sachen. Man kann jetzt irgendwo Farben einstellen, wo man vorher keine Farben
einstellen konnte. Und man kann in der Taskleiste vielleicht irgendwas ausklappen, was man vorher
nicht ausklappen konnte. Und wenn's ganz hart kommt, wenn's ganz hart kommt, wenn Microsoft
ja wirklich die Innovationskeule wieder auspackt, dann können wir vielleicht einen neuen Dialog
in den System-Settings jetzt verwenden, anstatt dass man ins alte System-Control-Panel wieder
muss. Aber viel mehr erwarte ich davon nicht. Vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht irgendwelche
alten Funktionen abgeschaltet, die nützlich waren, das machen sie auch gerne. Und eventuell
Cortana-Zwangsintegration weiter verbessert. Also verbessert, ne? Also viel mehr kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen, dass das passiert. Gucken wir uns mal an. Muss mal kurz ein Video zulassen,
ich guck, kann auch klaren. Geht, oder? Lautstärke ist ok. Der erinnert mich übelst
von der Aussprache an irgendjemand anderes auf YouTube. Der, der auch immer so übelst
glücklich klingt. Fällt mir jetzt bloß grad nicht mehr ein. Matze2090, fünf Monate Dankeschön
für den Sub.
Was bedeutet, es wird Zeit für ein neues Update-Video, in dem ich euch alle Neuerungen
des Oktober 2020-Updates vorstelle. Da war Microsoft wieder ganz kreativ mit der Namensgebung,
denn das Update kommt offensichtlich Ende Oktober und Anfang November. Ah ja, by the
way, das habe ich schon gelesen. Die Updates wurden jetzt unbenannt. Normalerweise würde
das Update 2010 heißen, aber Microsoft hat festgestellt, Scheiße, wir schaffen es nicht,
unsere eigenen Update-Nummern einzuhalten. Weil 2004 kam ja auch eher in 2006, so nach
dem Motto. Und jetzt haben sie sich überlegt, sie nennen es nicht 2010, was eigentlich sinnvoll
wäre, was jetzt auch die normale Namensgebung bisher wäre, sondern jetzt nennen sie es 20H2
für zweites Halbjahr 2020. Bitte etwas lauter, ok kann ich gleich machen. Imp079 schreibt
Wunsch, Windgatt und Verbesserung ihres SSHs. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie SSH drauf
haben. Ja, aber Windgatt haben sie schon ein bisschen verkackt. Ich mein, wozu brauchst
du einen Paketmanager, der keine Pakete entfernen kann? Muss man sich überlegen. Das ist also
eine der grundlegendsten Funktionen von einem Paketmanager. Sollte sein hinzufügen, entfernen
und updaten von Paketen. Und was macht Microsoft? Hinzufügen, updaten, ok, entfernen brauchen
wir nicht. Die haben wirklich einen Paketmanager eingebaut, der nichts entfernen kann. Das
ist wirklich fail. Ja, alles ist besser als der offizielle Microsoft. Ok, ich mach ein
bisschen lauter. Falls ihr euch das Video ein bisschen später anschaut, schaut mal
in den Kommentarbereich. Dort werde ich nämlich einfach mal ein Kommentar anpinnen, wo ich
schreibe, das Update ist verfügbar und wenn da halt kein Kommentar von mir angepinnt ist,
dann wisst ihr, das Update ist noch nicht da. Ihr müsst eigentlich gar nicht danach suchen.
Falls es dann erscheint, wird es als optionales Update angeboten. Achso, Moment, ich wollte
doch vorhin noch etwas beantworten. Habe ich doch gesagt, mal kurz hochscrollen. Folgendes
gesagt, ich beantworte gleich den Chat. Was war denn das nochmal? Ich dachte ich sag gleich
was zu. Ich hab glaub ich nie was zu gesagt. Wartet mal, was war das denn? Ich scroll grad
mal hoch. Also genau, der Umut hat gefragt hier, dieses. Oha, ich bin ja blind. Hat irgendwas
gefragt, aber das hab ich noch gar nicht auf. Also er hatte gefragt, er überlegt sich
dieses Board zu kaufen, um da draussen nass zu bauen. Ob ich mir das mal angucken kann?
Kann ich mir angucken. Also exellent. Oh, das sieht da schon so richtig Business Style
mäßig aus. S-Rock Rack, die sind schon mal nicht verkehrt. Von denen hatte ich auch
ein Board für meine 4HE-Kiste. Ich wusste bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt übrigens gar nicht,
dass S-Rock versucht irgendwelche AZ-Hardware herzustellen. Und Noobrunner kann man ganz
schnell beantworten. Er hat nämlich gefragt, ging das Steckdose nach dem Neuflaschen? Hab
ich noch nicht gemacht. Oh, beste. Das Final Fantasy Overworld Musik. Exquisite. So, zeig
mal her, was hat denn das Board? Was, ist das ein Achter? Ist das ein Achter PCIe Express?
Kennst du dich mit Windows aus? Nee. Ist das ein Achter PCIe Express? Das ist so eine komische
Länge, die man normalerweise nicht sieht. Ohje, für das Upgraden geht auch nicht. Achter,
du hast auf jeden Fall ein Management-Interface hier hinten dabei, denke ich. Machst du, ah,
guck mal hier sogar eine Mini, Mini-Sat 2, eine Mini-Sat Connector, das ist schon mal
gut. Ich vermute mal, diese Art der Dinge haben Stromversorgung, dass man so einen kleinen
Blick drauf machen kann. Benutzt du eine geänderte Windows-Version? Verstehst du unter einer
geänderten Windows-Version? Nö. Warum auch? Also, wozu? Hä? Revios? Nö. Sehe ich den
Sinn nicht so drin. Ich hab da letztens mal, ich hab da sogar glaube ich auf meiner To-do-List
für einen Stream gestehen, das mal auszuprobieren, aber ich bin da immer skeptisch, was so Custom-Sachen
angeht, weil lassen wir mal diese Telemetriesachen und Candy Crush und sowas außen vor. Also,
die meisten tunable Sachen hat Microsoft nicht umsonst auf einen Default-Wert gestellt,
der mehr oder weniger sinnvoll ist. Also, natürlich kann man Candy Crush und Gedöns
entfernen, das ist sinnlos, aber wenn die dann anfangen, irgendwelche Netzwerkparameter
und sowas zu tunen, dann frag ich mich, ob das wirklich so sinnvoll ist. Gerade am besten
sind diese Netzwerk-Tunen-Videos, die irgendwelche TCP-Settings ändern und dann einen Ping machen.
Das ist so richtig Pains-Champ immer. So nach dem Motto, ich mach jetzt hier TCP-Receive-Winner
und danach mach ich einen Ping. Kennt ihr diese Videos, die sind so richtig... Low-Brain.
Muss mal kurz muten und husten. So, also was hat denn das drauf? VGA, klar, wir sind ja
LZ-mäßig unterwegs, 32G RAM. Ist das Embedded-CPU? Ja, was ist da drauf? Was für eine CPU ist
da drauf? Ein Atom. Ja, ich glaub, das ist ein ganz gutes Nassbild, ein ganz gutes Nassbord.
Also, damit kann man auf jeden Fall was bauen. Die Sache ist die, ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
wie taufrisch die CPU ist, ob sich das tatsächlich lohnt oder ob das nicht schon eine tote mehr
oder weniger Dead-Plattform ist, was nicht schlimm ist, weil wenn's geht, dann geht's.
Also, vom ersten Blick ist das, glaub ich, ein ganz gutes Board. Das wird aber nicht
so extrem stromsparend sein wie andere Low-Power-Intel-Boards, weil das ja ein paar RZ-Features hat. Du hast
da bestimmt auch irgendein Management-Interface drauf, denk ich. Weiß nicht, ob man das
hier sieht. Also, eins hier vorn ist das da wahrscheinlich, ist bestimmt ein Management-Interface,
das braucht also auch permanent Strom. Also, du wirst es nicht extrem Low-Power bekommen,
aber wahrscheinlich relativ Low-Power. Was ganz gut ist, es gibt für diese Boards gibt
es manchmal Reviews. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das dafür auch gibt. Ne, okay, die haben dazu
keine Reviews gewonnen. Aber die haben ganz gute Reviews, was so Low-Power-Boards angeht
und so. Was würde gegen Scoop und Choco springen? Nix. Alle mal besser als Winged. So, gucken
wir mal weiter. Was für Neuerungen gibt's vom Oktober-Update? Also, ich verwende eigentlich
nur noch Scoop. Das reicht mir. Lokalpaket installieren, gut, ist fast alles drin, was
man braucht. Ich finde, da klingt übelst gehypt und glücklich der Sprecher. Die neuen
Windows-Funktionen sind am Start. Ist eigentlich cool, dass er so ein trockenes Thema mit der
nötigen Motivation sprechen kann. Ich würde wahrscheinlich mich hinstellen und sagen,
Microsoft hat wieder ein neues Update veröffentlicht, man kann drei Buttons ändern und die Taskleiste
ist jetzt transparent. Okay, tschüss. 20 Minuten? Was haben die da alles reingepackt,
ne? Ja, sondern 20H2. Da ist Microsoft ja gut drinne. Sobald man sich an was gewöhnt
hat, wird es umbenannt. Das ist genauso wie Office 365 jetzt umbenannt, ne, warte mal,
nicht das durcheinander bringen. Doch, Office 365 wird umbenannt, ne? Office 365 wird umbenannt.
Ne, genau, Office wird in Microsoft 365, ne, oder wie war das nochmal? Genau, Office 365
ist jetzt Microsoft 365 oder irgendwie sowas, oder umgedreht, oder was auch immer. Also
bei Microsoft kann man sich an Namen wirklich nicht, also es lohnt sich nicht, Namen zu
merken. Ja, das Xbox Interface ist auch jedes Jahr anders. Ziffern der neuen Versionsnummer
fangen mit den letzten zwei Ziffern des Jahres an. Das heißt, im Endeffekt, die haben das
Jahr 2020, die letzten zwei Ziffern sind 20 und die Versionsnummer... Woher weiß er,
dass es die letzten zwei Ziffern sind? Können sich auch die ersten zwei Ziffern sein. Die
Versionsnummer fängt dann mit 20 an. Sie wird fortgeführt durch ein H und dieses H steht
für die Jahreshälfte und daran angehangen wird dann eine 1 oder eine 2. Das bedeutet
im Endeffekt die erste oder die zweite Jahreshälfte. Und da dieses Update im Oktober 2020 erscheint,
trägt dieses Update die Versionsnummer 20H2. Und falls ihr beim nächsten Video wieder dabei
seid, was mich mega freuen würde, weil ich stelle euch jedes halbe Jahr alle Neuerungen
Windows Updates vor. Dann sehen wir uns später für die Versionsnummer ein. Ich kann mir
das richtig gut vorstellen, dass dann irgendwann kommt 21Q3 oder sowas. Du hast 20H3. Das
wird mich auch nicht wundern, wenn es Microsoft irgendwie schafft eine dritte Jahreshälfte
einzuführen. 21H1 wieder und dieses Update wird versprochen auch größer als das hier,
denn das ist so ein kleines Update, so ein Aktivierungsupdate. Ihr lädt einfach nur
1MB runter, geht super schnell, ihr könnt es bedecken. Das Update ist 1MB groß und dafür
gibt es 20. Ok. Also da, guck mal, 1MB Update und er kann ein 20 Minuten Video machen. 50
Gigabyte Modern Warfare Update und du kannst dir neue Waffenskillen angucken. Also irgendwie
stimmt das verhältnismäßig. Keine Angst haben, es braucht nicht 3 Stunden und dann
ist euer Windows auf dem neuesten Stand. Ihr habt ein paar Neuerungen, Microsoft Update
rausgehauen, alles perfekt. So und steigen wir direkt mit der ersten Neuerung ein. Ok,
es ist keine echte Neuerung, es ist eher eine optische Veränderung und zwar am Startmenü,
aber keine voreilige Vorfreude, die Live-Kacheln sind noch da. Letztens hatten sie einen Mini-Update
in Modern Warfare, das war nur 250MB und da haben sich alle gefragt, wie schaffen die
das. Und wir waren uns nicht sicher, hat sich überhaupt was geändert, vielleicht ein Spray
geändert von blau auf grün oder so. Allerdings sieht das ganze jetzt deutlich homogener und...
Ok, wo ist der Unterschied? Wo ist der Unterschied? Hä? Wo ist der Unterschied? Ich sehe da
ja keinen Unterschied. Stimmt, der Hintergrund ist weg. Die Icons haben kein Hintergrund
mehr. Krasse Neuerung, Alter. Huiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiui. Da haben sie sich aber richtig ins
Zeug gelegt bei Microsoft. Aus einem Guß aus. Das liegt daran, dass die Live-Kacheln
jetzt nicht mehr wie zuvor die Akzentfarbe... Ah, so einen Moment, die Kachel habe ich
gar nicht eingeblendet da hätte ich vielleicht mehr gesehen eine definierte
vordefinierte farbe tragen sondern die systemfarbe und das folger das folger
eiken sieht anders aus ja tatsächlich und excel ist vielleicht ein bisschen
klein oder mini mini x ist das hier das excel wenn die ihre eigenen eiken schon
nicht hinkriegen startmenü auch dunkle live kacheln so ich habe jetzt meine
windowsfarbe auf hell gesetzt und ihr seht direkt die live kacheln haben
ebenfalls die systemfarbe übernommen und hätte ich jetzt ein kontrastreicheres
hintergrund bild wo viel mehr los wäre würdet ihr auch sehen dass die kacheln
leicht durch der blinde also der hintergrund schimmert leicht aber was die
nicht hin ach so meint es ist absicht dass das door logo in wörtet wird ok was
mir persönlich extrem zusagt ist die tatsache dass bei der setzung der
akzentfarbe auf systemelemente wie die tatsache das wetter schafft nicht
wahrscheinlich weil das ein animierter hintergrund ist und das keine
transparenz unterstützt oder sowas dass das wird es wird wieder das wäre so eine
typisch inkonsequente microsoft geschichte ebenfalls die live kacheln
auch in der farbe erscheinen deswegen können wir so coole grüne live kacheln
haben oder wenn wir in den einstellungen mal nachschauen
ja ist es nicht im letzten video auch und ich meine das ist jetzt ist das
settings bin ich recht erst mal am vorstellen exzellent wird der aufnahme
und das ist jetzt zum ersten mal gequatscht und es ist wahrscheinlich die
aufnahme die ich jetzt nehmen werde ja ok pech gehabt zumindest die farbe
flaume sieht ziemlich schön aus da möchte ich euch mal davon geben
es sieht wirklich richtig schön aus und ich bin sehr froh dass microsoft diese
ok über geschmack kann man streiten mein fall ist es nicht unternommen hat
allerdings sind die live kacheln nicht das einzige was verändert wurde sondern
links übrigens wetter kriegt immer noch nicht hin ja auch hier bei den app
eikens fehlen jetzt die farben boxen stimmt stimmt das haben wir auch gerade
festgestellt hier guck mal dass es
ja das sieht schon besser aus das sieht schon besser aus aber wahnsinn was
eine geile änderung oder also da hat sich wirklich das innovations team
microsoft wieder richtig mühe gegeben bei eine box entfährt im startmenü
wahnsinn krasse eikens stehen jetzt alleine für sich und das sorgt noch mal
dafür dass das alles ein bisschen dass sie das überhaupt hinbekommen haben in
einem halben jahr also da haben die schon ganz schön gespitzt für es ist
sozusagen die live kacheln sind jetzt eher im hintergrund gerückt so ich habe
die einstellung wieder zurück gesetzt damit wir direkt mit den nächsten
neuerungen weitermachen können die auch rein optischer natur ist allerdings auch
ziemlich cool es ist wirklich eine kleinigkeit und zwar löse ich jetzt mal
wisst ihr was die geilste news überhaupt wer microsoft windows unterstützt jetzt
twitch emotes wäre das nicht geil
da könntest du überall in windows schreiben pochamp und es kommt das
passende das wäre mal innovation oder inklusive betta twitch tv und ffz
emotes wird zwar nie passieren aber das das wäre mal
innovation
musenig für 15 monate excellent eigentlich für den sub das ist ja schon
richtig
die wetter hat noch ein update kommt ja kann schon sein
benachrichtigungen aus indem ich einen screenshot erstelle von meinem desktop
und wir sehen direkt hier die benachrichtigung trägt jetzt ein eil
und ich wusste gar nicht dass da überhaupt ne benachrichtigung kommt
Warte mal, Snap, Snipping Tool, was, Moment wie geht das überhaupt, von mir kommt da keine
Benachrichtigung, wie hat der das gemacht, Win, Shift und S, Win, Shift, S, aaaah,
Moment, hab ich schon die neue Windows Version, kann das sein, weil bei mir ist auch ein Icon
da, der hat gerade gesagt, also guck hier, das Icon ist am Start, aber bei mir hat es
auch einen Icon, hab ich jetzt die neue, oder stimmt das nicht, und es hat einen Icon, weg
damit.
Und das ist in der Hinsicht sehr sinnvoll, dass wenn wir gerade am Arbeiten sind, kommt
eine Benachrichtigung ein und das erste was wir wissen wollen ist, woher kommt diese Benachrichtigung
und bislang mussten wir den Titel, ich guck mal, ich guck mal, ich guck mal was ich finde.
Ja, ich hab 2004, was eigentlich nach Microsoft Logik jetzt 20h1 sein müsste, benutzt eigentlich
irgendjemand diese Windows Benachrichtigungen, ich klick die immer weg, das einzige was da
kommt ist, Windows Defender hat seit 14 Tagen keine Bedrohung gefunden, das ist instant weg,
ich würd sofort ausschalten, wenn man das ausschalten könnte.
Bildern arbeitet und wir sowieso immer die Icons der Apps kennen, die wir sowieso nutzen,
ist es ganz praktisch, dass jetzt ein Icon da steht, also wir gucken nur kurz das Icon
an und wissen direkt, aha, das ist jetzt eine Telegram Nachricht und wir können direkt im
Gehirn weiter arbeiten.
Das ist Windows A, guck mal hier, Chat, hier lernt man auch was, Windows A, was, Turn Off
Reminders, U-Modus, es ist komplett useless, zumindest es gibt jetzt einen Icon, was es
bei mir auch schon gibt, ok alles klar.
Und dieser X-Button wird jetzt immer dargestellt, vorher war ja immer ausgeblendet, außer man
fährt mit der Maus drüber und jetzt ist er immer sichtbar.
Boah, alter Microsoft ey, die hauen hier aber ein Ding nach dem anderen raus, jetzt hat
man sogar einen immer sichtbaren Close-Button, du Scheiße, da kann sich Apple aber echt
warm anziehen.
Aber genug über die Optik geredet, kommen jetzt auch zu Sachen, die man wirklich nutzen
kann und deswegen öffnen wir einmal die Einstellungen, denn hier hat sich vor allem im Eintragsystem
ein paar Sachen getan, fangen wir an direkt mit den Anzeigeeinstellungen, denn wenn wir
hier runterscrollen, dann finden wir erweiterte Anzeigeeinstellungen und hier klicken wir
einmal drauf und wir sehen direkt, ah, haben sie es endlich geschafft, man kann die Auflösung
über den normalen Windows Dialog ändern, bisher musste man das immer so machen, Display
Settings, Advanced Settings und dann Display Adapter Properties for Display One, Monitor
Refresh Rate, also sowas absolut hängen gebliebenes gibt es echt nur unter Windows, ich meine,
wer hat sich das überlegt, wer hat sich bei Microsoft gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
Okay, aber endlich, endlich, ich meine, das sollte eigentlich schon seit Release drinne
sein, ja man kann es auch über das NVIDIA Menü machen, aber das ist so fail, das ist
so fail, zumindest haben sie es jetzt geschafft, das ist ja schon mal gut, endlich, endlich,
240 Hertz, ja klar, ja unter maximalen FPS und dementsprechend, Herz mache ich ja nicht,
muss 240 Hertz sein, Weird Jam, die haben so ein bisschen Rundungsprobleme hier, oder?
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, warum es hier so ein komisches Float ist, anstatt eine aufgerundete,
keine Ahnung, Microsoft Logik.
Für die nächste Neuerung klicken wir mal auf Info, vielleicht wirkt das irgendwie technischer
und besser, wenn das dann nicht 144, sondern 143,931 sind, was, darf ich euch mal, ich
muss mich jetzt mal wieder einmal als Boomer outen, werde ich euch mal sagen, mir gefällt
das Systemsteuerungsmenü viel besser als das neue UWP-Settings-Menü, habe ich das
richtig gesehen, habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen, Sekunde, Leute, was ist das, Pains
Champ, was, warum ist da der Flash-Player drauf, MonkaS, ja gut, für Farmville braucht
man das, aber Farmville wird jetzt eingestellt, weil es keiner auf HTML5 portieren will,
weiß ich, ob ihr es gelesen habt, Farmville spielt eh kein Mensch mehr, ja.
Klicke, öffnet es ab jetzt hier die Info in den neuen Einstellungen, denn diese Seite
hat die alte nun vollständig ersetzt, damit das überhaupt möglich ist, weiß nicht, ob
das gut oder schlecht ist, natürlich etwas erweitert, und zwar dahingehend, dass auf
der rechten Seite ein paar Verknüpfungen zu wichtigen Einstellungen sind, das war einer
der größten Use-Cases, wieso die Leute überhaupt die alte Systeminfo geöffnet haben, beispielsweise
um schnell hier den Computer zu schicken, aber das ist noch das alte Menü, so schlecht,
die haben es gerade mal geschafft, hier drei Dinge, und dann linken sie noch aufs alte
Menü, ist das scheiße, oh Gott, wisst ihr, die haben jetzt, das heißt, man musste früher
in die alte Systemsteuerung, um den alten Systemdialog aufzumachen, um dann in diesen Systemeigenschaften-Dialog
zu kommen, das einzige, was die jetzt gemacht haben, ist, dass auf das neue Fenster verlinkt,
was dann wieder in das alte, in das alte reingeht, das ist so unglaublich fail, oh Mann, warum
sind diese alten Dinge überhaupt noch da, also entweder hätte man sagen sollen, ey,
dieses UWP-Settings-Geschiss, schmeißen wir raus und wir machen irgendwie mal ordentliche
Systemsettings, okay, aber wenn man sich dafür entscheidet, wir machen diese UWP-Systemsettings,
dann macht halt alle Systemsettings endlich mal in UWP rein, so schwer kann das doch nicht
sein, lass das mal irgendwie 50 Dialogfenster sein oder so, das müsst ihr doch bei Microsoft
geschissen kriegen, ich hab das Gefühl, das ist so die Schleife, die bis zu, okay, nee,
das muss ich anders erzählen, also es gab ja mal so diesen Witz, wenn man ein Programm
hat, wo man regelmäßig Updates rausbringen muss, das heißt, man macht das erste Mal
eine Schleife rein, die einfach nur nichts macht, aber bis 30 Milliarden zählt, so und
bei jedem Update machst du einfach eine Null weg und sagst hier Update Performance Improvements
und ich hab den Eindruck, diese Dialogfenster ist so diese Schleife für Microsoft, sie
machen eigentlich kaum was, aber um zu zeigen, sie machen was, wird ab und zu mal ein altes
Systemsteuerungsfenster ersetzt durch ein neues UWP-Dialogfenster, was überhaupt kein großer
Akt sein kann, weil die Settings unter der Haube funktionieren ja komplett unabhängig
vom Dialogfenster, okay, das ist tatsächlich praktisch, da kann man jetzt zu gutefrage.de
gehen und sagen, hier mein Rechner geht nicht, könnt ihr mir sagen, woran das liegt, copy,
das heißt easy, PC-Probleme habt und der euer Gegenüber wissen möchte, wie sieht es überhaupt
in dem Inneren eures Computers aus, könnt ihr das hier einfach kopieren und ihm zusenden
und er weiß dann ungefähr Bescheid, besonders praktisch, das ist gut, simuliere mächtige
Startzeit, eigentlich ist es gar nicht blöd so was zu machen, weil wenn das von Anfang
an zu gut ist, dass es widerspricht so ein bisschen, wie soll man das aussprechen, so
eine Programmierere, die man vielleicht hat, dass man Sachen absichtlich langsamer macht,
aber eigentlich ist das an sich gar nicht schlecht, wenn das so ein Ding ist, wo man
jetzt schon weiß, die verkaufen irgendwelche Support-Verträge oder sonst was und was willst
du großartig machen, außer dass irgendwann jede Software einen mp3-Player oder so ein
Schwachsinn drin hat, einfach jedes Mal sagen, neues Update Performance Improvements, wenn
du keine Performance Improven kannst, ohne weiteres, machst du es halt künstlich langsamer,
so doof ist die, so blöd es klingt, aber so doof ist die Idee eigentlich gar nicht,
deswegen finde ich es gut, dass das bei euch aber live so war, jetzt drehen sie aber auf
bei Microsoft, gute Frage Happyprinter, muss das sein?
Ja, Gott sei Dank, endlich, endlich, ich konnte es kaum erwarten, dass der Startup nicht mit
dabei ist, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank,
Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank, Gott sei Dank,
ist auch ein paar vorzüge also ein paar extra features falls euch also für den
neuer übrigens ich flamme wenn es nicht das jetzt ist fies anhört ich flamme
nicht ihn oder so der macht das video wirklich gut für die paar sachen die
microsoft eingebaut ich flamme eher microsoft interessiert dann schaut mal
oben rechts da wird jetzt eine infokarte aufploppen könnt ihr auch später noch
mal nachschauen da hat mein kollege albert ein richtig gutes video zum neuen
edge bowser erstellt da erzählt euch alles darüber und wie er so aussieht und
so weiter so öffnen wir jetzt mal den edge bowser in der kennery version also
in einer beta version und ich habe hier schon mal was vor uns kommt jetzt kommen
jetzt kommen es kommen auch noch hier die testversion von edge bleeding edge
microsoft technologie nämlich auf windows area punkt die und ich habe ein
paar neue antike geöffnet beispielsweise wurde der windows xp source code geleaked
worauf wir uns natürlich alle freuen also die erste neuerung ist nämlich eine
tiefere integration ins system mit alt und ab hier sehen wir meine einzelnen
browser tabs werden ja jetzt in alt ab dargestellt aber das sagt das sagt wer
will denn sowas haben das das ist doch leute ich habe 40 tabs auf da kann ich
alt ab absolut nicht verwenden das ist übelst kacke
wer macht denn sowas sieht es aus das ist einfach dafür da damit man schnell
zwischen den zuletzt machten sowas kann man ausstellen hoffentlich gut man darf
absehen ich verwende ich verstehe verwende eh kein edge und ihr seht
direkt wenn ich zum beispiel an diesem tab und an diesem tab arbeite immer
hin und her wechsel war das bislang nicht so leicht wenn ich nehme ich kann
einfach drauf klingen die tasten kombination vom bowser nutze dann geht
das nur tab weises ein tab zurück noch ein tab zurück und noch ein tab zurück
und jetzt bin ich wieder zum rechten tab da muss ich hier durch alle tabs durch
konnte man konnte man nicht auch schon in chrome irgendwie alt und ende oder
irgendwie sowas drücken
das nicht auch
keine ahnung ob das aber ich verwende das eh nicht also ich muss euch sagen ich
verwende keine shortcuts für tabs ich also nicht zum tab switchen ich
verwende nur shortcuts für tab aufmachen und das beste shortcut leute was mich
ja immer noch überrascht dass das viele leute nicht kennen oder nicht benutzen
ist das hier also ich mache ich mache mal hier google auf und jetzt habe ich
google aus versehen zugemacht steuerung w hat mich verdrückt und so scheiße
eigentlich wollte ich doch noch was nachgucken dann kann man steuerung schiff
t drücken steuerung schiff t macht das letzte tab wieder auf geht übrigens in
chrome und in firefox das ist eigentlich also steuerung schiff
t ist glaube ich neben control t so was wichtig ist das meist benutzte tab
feature überhaupt weil ich meine es es passiert schon wirklich oft dass man
mal keine ahnung irgendwie ein bisschen tiefer auf einer seite drauf ist keine
ahnung man liest hier gerade in heise artikel oder sonst was in den commons und
guckt hier gerade durch und stellt fest ah hier das wollte ich
alter monka corona weiß ich ob man es gehört hat also keine ahnung ich mache
jetzt hier zu na ja fuck das wollte ich noch lesen mache ich einfach wieder auf
zack geht es an der stelle weiter exzellent hecker richtige hackertipps
heute wieder so weiter
wollen sag mal warum bekomme ich hier werbung für die super ultra nerf gun was
für ein ding jetzt einfach sagen ich nutze den tab und den und immer wenn v
wenn v ist die zwischen ablage die habe ich aber ausgeschaltet und ich kann
hier sachen raus kopieren oder was weiß ich das ist ein häufiges use case
einfach im gehirn weiß man ich komme zurück mit alt hab barm ich bin zurück
gekehrt allerdings weiß microsoft natürlich es gibt leute die haben 50
tabs offen ja ja ja ja kann ich mich voll damit
identifizieren ich für neue videos recherchieren deswegen kann man das
feature auch konfigurieren in den einstellungen und wir kehren dann
wieder hier zurück und zwar unter system klicken wir einmal auf multitasking und
hier gibt es jetzt den eintrag alt plus tab und hier haben wir die auswahl
zwischen folgenden ok das hätte ich nie gefunden aber gut zu wissen dass es
gibt standardmäßig fenster und fünf
aktuelle registrierkarten registrieren ist die ist da was kann den fehlen habe
ich erletzt
deswegen habe ich mal bin aus auf englisch eingestellt
weil ich wenn ich mal nach einer fehlermeldung suchen würde würde ich
garantiert nicht suchen etsch registrerkarten fehler sondern etsch tab
error keine sorge ich habe mich jetzt korrigiert man lernt nie aus
perfekt hier kann man auch einstellen dass alle registrerkarten also tabs von
etsch im alt tab erscheinen sollen wie gesagt fünf oder nur drei stück ist eine
gute balance finde ich oder nur fenster öffnen das ist eine schreckliche
deutsche übersetzung eigentlich sollte hier stehen nur offene fenster
wählen wir nämlich diese option an dann sehen wir direkt unter alt tab alle tabs
sind weg von etsch nur noch meine programme meine offenen programme werden
aufgelistet im endeffekt muss das sein deaktiviert so und das war nicht das
einzige es gibt nämlich in etsch noch die funktion dass wir webseiten an die
taskleiste anpinden können dafür klicken wir oben rechts auf die drei
punkte dann auf weitere tools und dann an taskleiste
choose my name da gebe ich dir recht warum sind die settings für etsch
bitte schön in den windows settings drinnen warum ist das nicht in den etsch
settings warum gibt es in den eigentlich müsste es wenn man es mal
richtig machen würde müsste es in den etsch settings so was geben wie keine
ahnung alt tab integration oder so und es müsste auch so gebaut sein dass das
potenziell andere software auch verwenden kann da würde ich das in etsch
weil ich hätte ehrlich gesagt zuerst in den etsch settings gesucht nicht in den
windows settings
anheften hier können wir noch name eingeben für den eintrag
man kann jetzt so wie ging das noch nicht ging das echt noch nicht
ich dachte man kann seit anfang an also ich habe das nie probiert aber ich hätte
vermutet dass man seit anfang an bookmarks in die taskleiste machen konnte
wundert mich also es ist gut dass es jetzt geht aber ich wundert dass es nicht
schon immer ging unten ist jetzt windows area das heißt wenn ich
schnell immer eine webseite aufrufen möchte klicke ich einfach auf windows
area bamm ist so wie eine verknüpfung so wie ein favorit öffnet sofort die
webseite und das hat microsoft jetzt erweitert ja aber ja ist dumm wenn das
in windows 7 schon funktioniert hat sind die chancen dass in windows 10 nicht
funktioniert sogar relativ hoch weil windows 10 hat ja ein komplett neues uwp
startmenü was es unter windows 7 noch nicht gab auch hier
wenn das sieben hat ja quasi das windows 98 startmenü mehr oder weniger noch
der karlsson 13 monate hütsch
dankeschön für den sub
drauf m core mit drei drei monate dankeschön für den sub hütsch subscriptions
ja genau jetzt sind die da ok man kann es verknüpfen mit mit ok hier seht ihr
jetzt jedes tab von windows area jede gisterkarte wird als eigenes fenster hier
dargestellt was richtig cool ist das habe ich übrigens ausgeschaltet das
ist das erste was ich unter windows immer ausschalte diese gruppierung ich habe
immer die einzelnen fenster offen als einzelne fenster also das fenster und
das fenster dieses gruppieren von anwendung geht mir mega auf den sack da
musste doppelt klicken und finde es trotzdem die sachen nicht richtig
ja wahnsinnsfortschritt hat das ganz ja das geht auch im weiteren sinn als nur
eine verknüpfung zu sein das heißt dann ich sehe direkt was habe
ich alles offen kann hin und her switchen es funktioniert perfekt außer die
vorschau dann bekomme so ein leeres fenster zu blick das wäre natürlich ja
auch noch was wenn einfach das feature funktionieren würde was hier nie so
schön aussieht aber trotzdem es funktioniert und ich finde es richtig
cool dass microsoft ihren edgebaus auch so ein bisschen mehr in das system
integriert natürlich zum nachteil der anderen aber ich meine wenn die software
von einem entwickler ist und das system gleichzeitig dann gibt es halt
vorzüge die man könnte einfach noch als stinknormale api sache in windows
einbauen wo man zugriff auf diesen alt tab dialog bekommt und da könnte es
jeder machen unter anderem edge das wäre eigentlich die logische variante aber
das natürlich nicht in der microsoft welt so was die nutzer nicht bieten
könnte so und schließen wir jetzt den microsoft edge browser und gehen zurück
hier in die einstellungen denn ich möchte euch noch zwei sachen vorstellen
die im letzten update video gar nicht drinnen waren allerdings mit der zeit in
version 2004 hinzugekommen sind dann wäre hier einmal der neue tablet modus
wie ihr seht wenn es es seit winnows geben gibt dann ist ja kein problem da
können sie anderen aufhören oder aber es geht in winnows 10 nicht mehr es gibt
auch ein paar dinge die winnows team ging und winnows 10 nicht mehr seit 20 h 2
kann man den klassischen tablet modus jetzt nicht mehr aktivieren wenn man
kein touch screen weil wie gesagt die task leiste ist ja seit winnows 10 auch
in so eine komische uvp ab
als gab es ja ein paar foren einträge wie ich mitbekommen habe dass leute
sich gewundert haben wieso plötzlich alles im vollbild modus auf ihrem pc
ist und irgendwie auf der task leiste die apps nicht mehr dargestellt werden
das wird jetzt nicht mehr passieren ihr könnt den tablet modus nur beitreten
auch wirklich touch screen gerät habe ich habe noch nicht einmal den tablet modus
verwendet verwendet jemand von euch den tablet modus
auch das vielleicht auf dem surface hab oder so nicht auf dem surface hat auf dem
surface book außerdem ist das ding heißt nicht
scheiße ja das weiß auch microsoft deswegen haben sie sich folgendes
überlegt statt den tablet modus der bisher in
winnows drinnen ist zu verbessern und vielleicht auch an das geniale winnows
acht mal heranzukommen sich so ein bisschen näher ein paar alte ansätze
wieder reinzubringen im system nope sie haben im endeffekt einen zusätzlichen
tablet modus eingefügt und dieser wird einfach so gestartet wenn ihr entweder
bei eurem surface die taster das ist ja auch eine typische microsoft logik man
hat eine funktion eingebaut die ist scheiße und man baut jetzt noch eine
zweite funktion ein dies auch scheiße und macht genau das gleiche aber es an
anderen ecken kacke als die andere funktion oder bei eurem 2 in 1 gerät die
tastatur nach hinten klappt dann wird folgendes geschehen hier unten in der
tas-leiste werden die abstände der einzelnen eigens erhöht damit ihr sie
leichter mit dem finger erreichen könnt außerdem damit man platz dafür hat wird
das suchfeld als suchs symbol eingeklappt keine anne er kann es ja nicht mal zeigen
weil es keinen touch mehr hat und die schaltflächen im explorer wären ebenfalls
größer das war es ihr habt weiterhin eure fenster und des
weiteren gibt es jetzt optionale updates hier auf der update seite hier werden
treiber updates angezeigt echt und tatsächlich wenn er jetzt in den
oh was kann ab denn ich habe ja auch das ist schon er hat ja auch gesagt das sind
sachen die gibt es seit der letzten version aber die sind ein bisschen
untergegangen hat er ja auch gesagt also das sind alte alte sachen
ok ich kann ab denn intel system
warum kann ich internet und internet doppelt abkühlen
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich das machen sollte soll ich das machen
2016 wat
1968 was ist das schon wieder
besser nicht mal unix time das ist microsoft time geräte manager geht und
hier einfach mal recht sich und treiber aktualisieren wählt kann man hier nicht
mehr im internet nach neuen treibern für das spezifische gerät hier suchen
hier seht ihr direkt option 1 wenn das durch sucht ihren computer nicht mehr
das internet oder hier manuell auf meinem computer nach neuen treibern suchen
das bedeutet wenn ich jetzt wissen will ob eine neue treiber version für mein
gerät vorhanden ist oder allgemein einfach treiber installieren will dann
mache ich das hier rüber hier könnt ihr einfach diese sachen an haben wir
installieren wollt und auf herunterladen und installieren klicken aber obacht hier
werden auch treiber updates dargestellt die ihr nicht unbedingt braucht und die
auch etwas älter sind das heißt solange ihr kein problem mit eurem computer
habt solange alles richtig funktioniert würde ich hier auch gar nicht
installieren belastet einfach wie es ist ich meine man sieht ja schon mal dran wie
fail das ist dass für das gleiche ist für die gleiche sache mehrere updates
drinstehen
warum und dann funktioniert wie gut wäre ein ordentlicher paket manager aber
nicht mit windows oder besser gesagt nicht mit microsoft
updates die einfach nur fehler beheben und nicht sicherheitsrelevant sind
angeboten das heißt wenn man beispielsweise in der aktuellen windows
version ein fehler besitzt den man unbedingt vermeiden möchte weil er
einen im workflow stört kann man einfach das neueste update installieren ja man
muss erst mal wissen für was man dafür vielleicht einen anderen fehler
inkauf der bis zur finalen fertigstellung noch gefixt werden muss
deswegen hier findet ihr auch manche sich backfix updates die nicht
sicherheitsrelevant sind etwas früher so und das war es auch im großen warum ist
das da nicht gekennzeichnet das ist wieder so wir das ist so mega kacke
gemacht wieder wenn es da sachen gibt die beta sind da soll das gefälligste
anstehen und wenn es da sachen gibt die security only sind soll das dranstehen
es ist total wir wieder warum ist das einfach nur so ein text string wo kein
mensch was mit anfangen kann backfix updates die nicht
sicherheitsrelevant sind etwas früher so und das war es auch im großen und ganz
schon jetzt werfen wir noch einen blick auf die feinen details ich euch auch
nicht zeigen kann dolby atmos unterstützt jetzt 24
bit audio bislang absolut nicht außerdem eine sache wenn ihr windows
frisch installiert wird nicht nur der edge borsa jetzt vor installiert sondern
hier unten ist ja immer das mail icon standardmäßig angebrannt
schlechteste mail app eu die nahe ist so schlecht die windows 10 mail ab weiß
gar nicht ob die überhaupt irgendjemand verwendet wenn ihr beispielsweise mit
eurem microsoft konto eine xbox verknüpft hat dann wird da unten die
xbox app zu sehen sein oder falls ihr beide einrichtung eure telefonnummer
eingibt um euer handy mit windows zu verknüpfen dann werdet ihr da unten die
smartphone app sehen einfach um euch den einstieg das gibt's in windows zu
erleichtern damit ihr direkt mit einem klick die benachrichtigung von eurem handy
an was 30 prozent verwenden die ernsthaft 30 prozent
btf wie kann man das verwenden ist eine nette sache einfach mal die task
leise so anzupassen wie der nutzer grad seinen computer eingerichtet hat im
schlimmsten fall ich würde erwarten dass die lustechtipps jetzt nicht die
kompletten nubs gucken auch viele nubs sonst wäre nicht so groß aber nicht die
komplett uninteressierten ich will einfach rechts liegt von task leicht zu
lösen und weg ist es und den rest kann man ja so schieben ja gut ist ja nichts
neues gut das war es auch schon mit dem video es sind ganz kurz ganz klein die
app ist so schlecht weil sie so ziemlich alles hat was mir ein uwp auf den sack
geht komisches interface funktionen die seit 20 jahren woanders gibt zum
beispiel dass man mails nach anhängen sortieren kann also nach anhängen und
zeit und so was sortieren kann wir sind nicht drinne
disclaimer ich habe das zum letzten mal vor zwei jahren mir angeguckt und
festgestellt es sacken danach nie wieder vielleicht kann es mittlerweile dass du
nichts
aber ich kriege sich rum dass du nicht anhänge automatisch ausblenden kannst
beziehungsweise anhänge nicht runterladen kannst es war ein parti es
war ein paar sachen ich habe mir das vor zwei jahren und es war so dermaßen
kacke die windows mail apps dass ich mich nicht weiter mit beschäftigt habe
aber ich verspreche euch das nächste update für 2021 und zwar das konter
meld auch nicht richtig verschieben mein guckt euch das mal an das ist nicht
absolute zumutung es gibt also dass das sinnvolle was
jeder verwenden kann ist an der börd das ist zwar jetzt keine optische
glanzleistung aber ist ok wenn ich sowas hier schon
seh das sieht einfach nur das sieht das sieht aus wie eine billige android mail
app
ja outlook kann man auch verwenden
genau verschieben zwischen den sachen hat nicht richtig funktioniert und so
was ganz wir ganz wir also ich würde einfach sanderbörd verwenden
wenn man nicht weiß was man verwenden soll
also das sein konnacht ju das ist das ist das ist die trainings mit die
konnacht die vier trainings mission in 8,8 5 sekunden krasser scheiß erinnert
sich da noch einer dran hier fucking new guy das war ich jetzt mal angucken
50.000 people used to live here and now it's a ghost town ok acht sekunden ich
glaube ich habe da irgendwie 30 sekunden für gebraucht oder so für die
trainings mission
oh
ane ok das war nix das war nix das hat so lange gedauert ok das war nix das war
nix next next mit hf
price kommt überhaupt nicht her mit hinterher mit den ansagen
ok jetzt jetzt hier world record kommt jetzt
krasser scheiß ich habe da irgendwie 30 sekunden für gebraucht oder so oder 45
sekunden oder sonst was
alter preis hast du die zeit mal angeguckt
mein headset hat aussetzer auf der linken seite war doch mal schluss bei kabel
kabel entführen kurz so jetzt geht's wieder
preis macht das in zehn sekunden ja aber der typ hat acht sekunden gebraucht
835 das aber das echt schon schon hart ok was haben wir hier
25 home automation auch das ist ein video für mich das ist ein video ich so als
als smart home fan bin ich mal gespannt was der hat das erste was man hier schon
sieht ist garage garage habe ich überlegt aber ist komplett sinnlos bei
mir mit der garage also garagen tour zu automatisieren weil da steht nichts
drinne meine garage ist reine abstellfläche für alte elektronik sachen
und kisten und und stühle und und tische und so das auto steht auf der
straße oder auf dem parkplatz damit direkt um die eckene parkplatz weil ich
kann das hofft so also wenn ich mein auto in die garage fahren
wollen würde jeden tag da müsste ich das hofftor neu machen lassen weil das
hofftor aktuell nicht automatisch auf und zu geht und jedes mal davor parken
aussteigen hofftor aufzeren rein fahren garage auf rein fahren zumachen hofftor
wieder abschließen zu mann ist mir zu doof
es gibt eine vorschrift ja wundert mich nicht wir haben in deutschland für alle
möglichen sachen irgendwelche vorschriften ich meine die geilste
vorschrift ist ja immer noch und das ist jetzt kein witz vielleicht vielleicht
hat es der ein oder andere von euch auch schon mal erfahrungen damit gemacht wir
haben den baum gefällt bei uns auf dem kunststück und wenn du einen baum auf
deinem eigenen kunststück fällst dann darfst du das erstmal nicht das darfst
du nur wenn du das quasi anmeldest und dann musst du einen ersatz baum pflanzen
der gewisse auflagen erfüllen muss also es muss eine spezielle sorte sein es
muss ein spezieller standort sein es muss eine gewisse größe haben und es
muss gesichert sein dass dieser baum für eine gewisse zeit auch im garten
verbleibt so und um das zu kontrollieren und das ist jetzt kein
witz kommt kommt ab und zu mal nen dude von der stadt und guckt sich diesen
ersatz baum an klingt abgedreht ist aber so
also dieses jahr war er nicht da ich glaube das ist jetzt mittlerweile auch
wurscht aber wir haben teilweise wirklich schon abgedrehte regelungen so jetzt
gucken wir uns mal 25 home automation ideas an mal gucken ob da was drin ist
was mir gefällt laut genug na oh exzellent da auf die da auf da da bin
drauf gekommen kennst du die video reale irrsinn
auf youtube und wenn der baum steht muss man dann auch für ersatz sorgen kann ich
mir gut vorstellen weil ich nicht
smart locks gibt es bei mir nicht smart locks mache ich nicht also ich wäre
vielleicht dazu bereit wenn ich im haus irgendwas abschließen würde oder so
also da einen smart lock dran ist mal angenommen
keine ahnung fürs klo oder so falls man abschließen will das wäre sinnvoll aber
ich würde nie für die haustür einen smart lock machen das ist eines der
sachen ich bin immer dafür irgendwelche sachen technisch auf zu ab zu
upgraden aber nicht für türschloss
warte ein kleines fernseher ich fasse den gleichen
now this video won't show you step-by-step how to do all of these automations
but it's meant to give you ideas I wrote everything down so you can check out the
article showing you how to do them ja kussi du hast recht du hast recht also
ich weiß nicht ob ich euch das im letzten stream gezeigt hat ich glaube
im letzten stream habe ich habe ich vergessen aber kennt ihr schon meine
heizungsüberwachung da kann man sich zum beispiel angucken was der brenner gerade
macht beziehungsweise ob die pumpe pumpt das ganze funktioniert über den
raspberry pi im keller der an die heizung angeschlossen ist dort läuft
im dotnet programm drauf und exportiert die die die daten und auf meinem server
hier läuft ein prometheus mit graf hana die das ganz wieder importiert
ich glaube ich sollte euch das noch öfters mal zeigen
so guck mal weiter ich habe letztes ich habe letzten stream vergessen eigentlich
muss ich das jeden stream machen so ok jetzt habe ich gar nicht aufgepasst
also wo ist er wo ist er gerade dabei
how to do all of these automations but it's meant to give you ideas I wrote
everything down so you can check out the article showing you how to do them if
you don't like reading I won't be offended because my name is read but you
should subscribe
der witz war so schlecht dass er eigentlich schon richtig gut war wieder
because I'll be covering how to do these in future videos all right we got 25
automations to cover enough of this talk let's get into it every morning at 7 a.m.
I have the light next to my bed slowly turn on to a nice cool white over 30
minutes until it's that's a good idea that's a really good idea that's something
I've thought about it before I have absolutely nothing except for the
christmas tree yes an rgb leuchten oder an dimmbaren lichten und so lichter
automatisierung lichtergeschichten ist noch komplett an mir vorbeigegangen aber
ich habe schon ein paar mal mit dem gedanken gespielt mich ein bisschen in
diesem thema mal ein bisschen was zu machen und das finde ich ist eine
ziemlich gute idee
full brightness that way it's much more comfortable to wake up and feel
energized by the cool white temperature of the light also it says good morning
good morning read I hope you slept well time to start waking up okay Alexa
kommt bei mir auch nicht hin
nice low volume in Mesa there's an excessive heat warning in effect until
wednesday kennst du tinker fortschbock online also ehrlich gesagt wenn ich wenn
ich mir ein motivations song spielen spielen würde morgens beim
aufstehen dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich den hier spielen lassen
Kona oder oder oder das hier
man darf ja nicht so viel spielen sonst ist gleich wieder sonst ist gleich wieder
hier copyright am start am start oder oder dass sie betet song ist auch nicht
schlecht dass sie betet song dass sie betet song ist auch gut
da müsste allerdings dass das noch funktioniert müsste man noch ein
randomizer einbauen für die wegzeit so nach dem motto eigentlich musste erst
um acht aufstehen der wecker geht um 6 30 an und dann kommt dann guckst du
drauf scheiße 6 30 die wecker jebait automation das werde man idee okay zu
spät wäre auch geil ja du musst sieben Uhr aufstehen es klingelt erst um acht
zu jutsche jutsche jutsche betet okay kommt mal weiter also so sind wir
stehen geblieben hier also irgendwie Alexa ansagen kommen mache ich auch gar
nicht ins haus ich habe keine ich habe keine springt das sieht aber richtig
ordentlich aus ich habe das ich habe das bei ein paar leuten schon gesehen jetzt
dass die dass die in laptop auf so einem komischen hänge ding haben was genau
bringt das also wozu wozu hat man sein laptop auf so einem hänge ding
das ist weil die max scheiß kühlung haben die oder das glaube ich nicht
aber was luft nein das kann nicht sein also das ding muss also die können
doch nicht die dinger können die so kacke gebaut sein dass das unten zu
heiß wird
damit der monitor gleich nösen ok
ich hätte da eine gute idee man stellte das laptop unten hin und macht sich hier
noch einen zweiten monitor daneben oder ich glaube ich deutlich praktischer
als wenn du das den laptop da immer rausfuddeln muss
kennst du irgendeinen gescheiten sprachassistenten den man rein
offline betreiben kann ne da bin ich selbst noch auf der suche nach was
gescheites telekom hat jetzt auch sprachassistenten auch gott die telekom
die wir bleiben wir bleiben echt aber vor nix verschont das müssen wir uns mal
kurz angucken telekom sprachassistent
die da so man bleibt echt vor nix verschont bei der telekom wie heißt das
wie heißt das denn jetzt mein alexa haben wir schon siri haben wir auch
cortana haben wir auch wie ist die wie ist die olle von der von der telekom früher
oder so wie ist sie was ist sie nicht so einmal in die telekom
sie nicht in die die die das schon ural ini genau aber ini würde ich nicht
sagen wollen hi hi ini das ist drauf telekom smart speaker mini warum genau
sollte ich den verwenden also wenn ich jetzt wenn ich schon einen assistent
verwenden will warum sollte ich mich nicht für siri alexa cortana google
assistent sonst wie entscheiden sondern ausgerechnet für telekom smart
haben wir ein video dazu das muss da muss man jetzt mal schnell ein video
angucken das wird so ein typischer telekom schnellschuss
hallo magenta ernsthaft nähe oder
das muss ich mir angucken ob das
das das muss ich muss mal kurz ein video dazu auf youtube suchen
hallo magenta es ist ernsthaft hallo magenta pains jam alda pains hallo magenta
das tut mir ja schon weh wenn ich das aussprechen muss ohne dass ich so was
habe hallo magenta nein ernst ich muss meinen kopf irgendwo dran hauen
hallo magenta
aktiviere die situation kino abend aktiviere die situation kino abend
ja natürlich vollkommen unge umgangssprachlich aber richtig
die situation keine keine szene keine irgendwie die situation kino abend ich
befinde mich jetzt hier in der situation kino abend
aktiviere die situation internet ausgefallen genau smart speaker sind
generell keine welt neuheit aber ein smart speaker mit sprachassistent aus
deutschland für deutschland das ist neu ja aber es ist doch scheiß egal ob der
aus deutschland kommt ob doch der versteht deutsch und hat viele plugins
und macht das was ich will und was der smart speaker der telekom so alles drauf
hat was das besondere an ihm ist das seht ihr heute bei den netzgeschichten
dann zeigt mal her sicher und bequem kein hin und her laufen keine lichtschalter
keine fernbedienung oder ab der smart speaker ist das für eine ultra hässliche
fernbedienung das sieht aus wie eine wie eine 5 5 dollar aliexpress billig
fernbedienung vor allem videotext tasten im jahr 2000 was die nun oder ab
der smart speaker steuert auf zuruf telekom dienste wie smart home oder
entertain tv na dann probieren wir doch mal aus wie das funktioniert hallo magenta
das tut schon so richtig weh das passt ziemlich gut an der stelle gerade er
guckt eher so kreis gassen mäßig
da mach mal das wohnzimmerlicht an erledigt das klappt hallo magenta suche
bei entertain tv nach better things erledigt ja meine serie ist schon mal auf
dem bildschirm jetzt frage ich mich nur wo mirko bleibt der wollte mich eigentlich
auch noch vorbeikommen ich rufe den mal hallo magenta ruft
ja ist gut dass man sich so richtig dazu darüber lehnen muss dass das
funktioniert neben den steuerungs funktionen der telekom services bietet
der smart speaker auch andere anwendungen wie die abfrage des wetters
das erstellen und verwalten einer to do oder shopping das gab es ja noch nie
dass man shoppinglisten darüber verwalten kann abfragen von news außerdem
fungiert der smart speaker auch als das video ist telekom werbevideo ja hallo
magenta spiele radio das ist der zuletzt gespielte sender hallo magenta stop radio
funktioniert also und der sound stimmt auch aber was passiert eigentlich mit
den ganzen sprachdaten was für ein absolut überflüssiger kack in sachen
daten hat der smart speaker einen entscheidenden vorteil denn er bietet
sehr hohen datenschutz nach den strengen deutschen sicherheitsstandards der
telekom und der europäischen datenschutz ja moment mal ganz davon
abgesehen die anderen müssen sich da auch dran halten
also es ist jetzt nicht so als wäre das wird es nur der telekom speaker machen
das ding heißt nicht umsonst verordnung da müssen sich die anderen auch dran
halten ob sie es machen sei mal dahingestellt aber sie müssten es werden
ausschließlich die daten gespeichert die den betrieb des geräts oder die
dienste des smartspeakers ermöglichen außerdem hat der kunde jederzeit das recht
einzelne daten oder auch komplett alle seine daten zu löschen
ja das geht sogar das geht sogar bei amazon und das heißt schon was review
muss wir das jetzt mal angucken ob das irgendeiner rechne oder dritte
weitergegeben hinten am gerät gibt es außerdem einen muteknopf
ich kann jederzeit selbstbestimmen das gerät aufhören sollen mir zuzuhören
ihr seht also smartspeaker ist nicht gleich smart doch das ist ziemlich
015 smartspeaker der wahrscheinlich sogar noch schlechter ist als die
anderen assistance
ok gibt es dazu eine review
super visionary ernsthaft
wer weiß mehr alexa oder hallo magenta ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass das
back-end entweder google gedöns ist oder amazon gedöns ist also ich glaube
noch nicht mal dass die telekom das irgendwie selbst gemacht hat ok warum
braucht die tl warum versucht die telekom eigentlich so krampfhaft mit
allen wie nennt man das so schön mit allen großen hunden pinkel zu gehen
irgendwie
die telekom macht game streaming macht smart home gedöns smart voice
assistant lautsprecher google cloud sonst was alles dinger die keine sau
benutzen will oder es ist von frauenhofer institut
entwickelt okay dann ist was eigenes dann hat dann hast du aber das problem wenn
es was telekom eigenes ist dass du zumindest dass du noch nicht mal die
vorteile davon hast wie beispielsweise dass du 50 milliarden alexa skills hast
also sprich wenn der telekom smartspeaker deine lokale müllabfuhr
nicht unterstützt kannst du es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so einfach
erweitern was ein stumpf sind alle warum muss das überhaupt sein
dein opa nutzt die maga anstatt es gibt leute magenta cloud verwenden also ich
habe mal unseren wer war das war das der escher der escher man
die escher schulung ich glaube in der in der allerersten escher schulung da hat
er gesagt diese diese diese escher 401 oder was das war die ich war die
allererste escher geschichte wo ich mal mitgemacht habe bei microsoft so und da
war diese da war der trainer am starten hat erklärt ja also sie unterstützen ja
auch das szenario dass man gewisse sachen in andere cloud plattformen
importiert oder exportiert und dann importiert nach microsoft oder exportiert
von escher und da habe ich ihn gefragt wie sieht das denn mit der magenta cloud
mit der magenta cloud aus das einzige was der trainer darauf gemacht hat ist das
hier so das war es so viel hat im thema magenta cloud zu sagen gehabt
motion sensor
du genau ok wir gucken jetzt mal dass sie die sinnvolle geschieht also er hat
sein seine rasen sprengt klar
also basti ich finde nicht dass das so sinnvoll ist dass man krampfhaft
versucht bei allen mitzumachen ich meine allein schon dieser dieser magenta
game streaming versuch das wirkt einfach so gewollt und nicht gekonnt dass es
schon wieder peinlich ist hast du schon mal was von microsoft ja hat mir überhaupt
nicht gefallen also ich bin auch noch auf der suche
nach irgendeiner voice assistant geschichte die man offline betreiben kann
und die halbwegs funktioniert und auch nicht gar so kompliziert ist
weiß nicht ob es da schon gute entwicklung für gibt aber jetzt gucken
wir uns erst mal an was der hier noch was der hier noch eingebaut hat
hallo magenta ich kriege also leute ich ich sage es jetzt nicht aber nur mal
dass man allein schon mal sieht wie unsinnig das ganze ist würde ich jetzt
quasi den namen des amazon voice assistant sagen würden bestimmt bei ein
paar von euch geräte im hintergrund angehen ja würde ich war würde würde
ich google cortana siri sonst was sagen würden bestimmt auch ein paar geräte
bei euch im hintergrund angehen sage ich aber hallo magenta geht bei
keinem von euch auch nur ein gerät an und das sagt wahrscheinlich alles auch
wenn wir jetzt nicht gerade super repräzentativ sind hier und ich weiß dass
jetzt gleich irgend einer im chat rollt und sagt doch mein hallo magenta ist
eben angegangen ich kann es ja schon prädikten was der chat macht ja
mittlerweile aber ich werde mit euch nirgendswo ist es angegangen
eine gewisse national autargie macht schon sind gebe ich dir recht neues
testament ich weiß aber nicht ob das gerade die
richtigen sachen sind wo die telekom an wenn man zum beispiel stromversorgung
wasserversorgung ja solche geschichten ja ja das macht essensversorgung für
notwendig das macht mit sicherheit sinn ob man jetzt den eigenen smart speaker
braucht der nur fünf prozent von dem kann was alle anderen können und es da
schon ein paar alternativen gibt ist echt fraglich ob das notwendig ist
ok gucken wir erst mal weiter
das ist eine gute idee das ist echt eine gute idee das ist so eine sache das
könnte man könnte ich auch machen also sprich wenn ich morgens aufstehe und ich
mache jetzt quasi nur home office gerade und wird wahrscheinlich bei uns noch
schlimmer werden die nächsten nächsten zeit übrigens wir haben jetzt auch den
ersten die die ersten corona fälle bei uns auf der arbeit und es wird
wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer werden die nächsten wochen denke ich so und wenn ich
ins büro gehe das wäre schon ganz cool wenn es erkennt ok es ist keine ahnung
37 oder so da max geht ins büro und er liest mir einfach die nächsten drei
kalendereinträge vor das wäre tatsächlich ganz nützlich weil lustigerweise
das erste was ich mache ist morgens entweder noch im bett oder wenn ich mich
remote eingeloggt habe ist in kalender gucken dass ich nicht irgendwelche
stonks meetings und agiles crumbs und was weiß ich sprints und und tribe
meetings und was da nicht alles gibt es war jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben das
gar so schlimm ist es nicht dass ich da nichts verpasse
das wäre gar nicht schlecht die idee finde ich gut
das wäre gar nicht schlecht die idee finde ich gut wie der home office ja die ganze zeit schon
das ist auch eine gute idee das ist auch hey das sind wirklich paar ganz gute
sachen bei überlegt euch mal man wir haben doch gestern im home assistant
eingerichtet dass der erkennt wann wie welcher zugverspätung hat das heißt ich
könnte mir durch sagen lassen so nach dem motto hey max du musst in zwei
minuten das haus verlassen das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute idee das
ist gut also das gefällt mir was der ausgedacht hat das sind nicht so sinnlose
sachen wisst ihr es gibt es gibt so heim automatisierungs videos da machen
dann okay ich darf zum thema steckdosen nicht sagen ja aber ich bin ich bin ja
selbst der wlan steckdosen und und steckdosen flash mann hier auf auf
twitch steckdosen wir schon im stream geflasht haben ist ja nicht mehr feierlich
aber es gibt halt videos die machen dann 10 10 steckdosen und und 10
temperatursensoren verteilen die im haus und sein hohe geil krasses krasses
smart home ohne dass es wirklich irgendwas smartes damit macht es zeigt
einfach nur auf dem tablet an und das bringt meistens nicht wirklich das sind
wirklich gute ideen von dem typ
so was habe ich mit der bahn verspätung
also wir haben zwei badezimmer das ist wurscht
okay das bräuchte ich das kommt mir nicht in die tüte kein kein nest auf
gar keinen fall nest
typischer ami schalter versuch mal bei uns so was in die wand zu kriegen
viel spaß
die smart things motion sensor has a temperatursensor built in
they can automatically turn on a fan if it starts getting hot and turn off the fan
gut das das mache ich mit der kleberlage ja auch schon
und i'm doing laundry i can be notified when my clothes are done drying even at
the timer still going i'm just using this little device that you can add to any
dryer just magnetizes inside the dryer and it will notify you when your clothes
are done drying or if the dryer stops in your clothes are still man könnte
einfach eine steckdose dranschließen den stromverbrauch misst oder ein rüttelsensor
dran machen oder so was in die schüssel pappen halte ich nicht für so sinnvoll
das wollte ich übrigens bei mir auch noch automatisieren haben wir schon ein
paar mal im stream besprochen dass man dass ich erkenne wenn der wäschtrockner
fertig ist der richtige heckermann
flash when someone's at the front door so i don't miss signing for a package as
i'm walking towards the front door i can see who's there on the brilliant light
switch screen oder mist auch die feuchtigkeit das tatsächlich ganz gut
und das automatisch habe ich jetzt nicht kapiert my lights in the house flash
when someone's at the front door so gute idee echt gute idee wenn es klingelt also
wenn man wenn man schon smart lighting hat ist es wirklich sinnvoll so was
einzubauen wie wenn es klingelt dass das licht flick flickert oder so das eine
coole sache
die deus am wagen towards the front door i can see who's there on the brilliant
das funktioniert bei mir auch schon ich habe zwar nicht so ein ding ich habe ein
tablet im flur hängen und ins tablet macht wenn es klingelt automatisch die
webcam auf vorm hof da bin ich old school muss ich sagen der robot haben
bei mir also und der hier im ersten stock steht den schalte ich meistens
manuell ein weil wenn der im wohnzimmer auch wohnzimmer putzen muss da muss ich
erst ein paar sachen hoch stellen das kann er da nicht putzen
deswegen lasse ich den nicht automatisch losfahren
im not to worried about coming home to any surprise by the way letztens hat
meine katz meine katz einen angstein flößenden encounter mit dem
staubsauger robotor
leider habe ich danach nicht mehr aufgenommen da habe ich danach nicht
mehr aufgenommen
die ist ja ein bisschen planlos was so was angeht erst mal hat sie überlegt
soll ich nicht soll ich den vielleicht anspringen oder so hat sich gedacht
nähe anspringen ist doch nicht so gut und dann hat sie sich hier hingelegt so
planlos wie sie ist der ist hierhin gefahren und ist dann von hinten an sie
ran gefahren und sie hat nicht geguckt und sie hat nicht geguckt und dann ist
ihr der ohne hin zu gucken ist ihr der robot auf bobs gefahren oder hat sie
einen riesen satz zwei meter aus dem wohnzimmer raus gemacht ich habe meine
katz noch nie so weit springen sehen das sah sie nicht so entspannt aus also hier
ist die tür wo ich hier ist die die eingangstür die ist quasi mehr oder
weniger von da gesprungen aus dem stand in flur
das
Sie sind so glücklich bin ich extrem glücklich
Ein spine 체 intra
ปบ because
nom projected
I look like dog
Loll
pronounced
Ja klar, das ist äußerst spannend, wenn da so ein komisches Ding rumfährt.
Hohohohoho, WCF
Das, aber da hast du gesehen, sobald der Erste springt, sobald der Erste springt, hüpfen sie alle. Das ist Standard.
Sobald der Erste springt, denkt jeder andere hoch, da ist was Schlimmes.
Welches Zigbee-Thermostat hast du, TroM?
Ähm, habe ich mir auch überlegt, aber habe ich für total sinnlos, äh, also dort wo das Wasser auslaufen würde, dann ist das wahrscheinlich eh nicht das Sensor, das großartig, ne.
Das gleiche, ja das funktioniert echt überraschend gut, weil das Problem mit dem Zigbee-Thermostat, das könnte aber auch daran liegen, weil es mir mal runtergefallen ist und ich es wieder zusammensetzen musste, der Knopf reagiert nicht so gut.
Also sprich, man muss schon ziemlich fest auf diesen Knopf vorne drauf hauen, dass das angeht.
Das Display
By the way, die Dinger, die hatten einen riesen Daten-Lack, die haben irgendwie, was weiß ich, 20 Millionen Kunden-Daten oder irgendwie sowas oder Wwise League, ne, Wwise League, ja, 2,4 Millionen Kunden-Daten haben die verloren und das Geile ist, auch Kunden-Daten von, also nicht nur von Kameras, auch von Vage und sonst was, also sprich, im Zweifelsfall haben die da, konnte man da Sachen abgreifen wie, äh, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo, wo.
Da konnte man da Sachen abgreifen wie, äh, Wohnort, Gewicht und ein Live-Feed von der Kamera, also das war ganz krasser Scheiß.
Und sie haben am Anfang auch behauptet, der Traffic ist verschlüsselt, da kommt keiner dran und, äh, am Ende kam raus, bei diesem Daten-Leak, dass man einen ungesicherten China-Server gefunden hat, wo man die Video-Feeds abgreifen könnte.
Schon die Open Beta-Gespiele, ja, gestern, gestern, vorgestern, gestern, 5 Stunden vorgestern, 2 Stunden.
Es ist, wie ich gesagt hab, Modern Warfare Reskin, mit ein paar Sachen entfernt, ein paar Sachen anders gemacht.
Äh, du hast mal von einem Rollanheber mit Custom-Firmware bei dir erzählt, welcher war das? Kann ich dir zeigen?
Das ist aber keine Custom-Firmware, die ich hab, das ist die Standard-Firmware, ich hab einen, so einen kleinen von denen, den billigsten.
Ne, den da nicht, so einen hier in der Richtung hab ich.
Ich hab das doch im Video gezeigt, ich hab das doch im Video mal gezeigt, China, hier, irgendwo hier hab ich das doch drinnen.
Hier, in der iPhone.
Ja, da ist er doch, ja.
Ja, ähm, ja, das ist keine Custom-Firmware, die da drauf ist, also damit kann man Rollläden runter machen, ich zeig's mal kurz.
Handlig.
Und dann zeig ich euch was Schwachsinniges noch.
Wow, Max, nicht so aggressiv, Alter.
Da hab ich hier einmal was Geiles, das ist ein elektrischer Rollanheber, den kann man jetzt mal hier rein machen, den Steckdosenleister.
Kogig.
Und, wenn man das einschaltet, dann kann man den Rollanheber runterfahren.
Und das cool an den Dingern ist, das ist natürlich auch...
So, und, ähm, was da wirklich ganz praktisch dran ist, man braucht keine Custom-Firmware, man kauft sich einfach den, äh, den Stick.
Man kauft sich den Stick von denen, übrigens, der Preis ist auch viel zu hoch, ich hab ihm 50 Euro oder so bezahlt.
Man kauft sich den Stick, ich meine 96 Euro für einen Stick, der ein bisschen funkgedönst macht, das ist halt voll der Witz, ne.
Das gibt's auch günstiger, guck hier, müsst ihr mal gucken, das ist viel zu teuer.
Und dann gibt's auf GitHub eine Library, mit dem man den ansprechen kann.
Ja.
Und mit dieser Library kannst du, und dem Stick, kannst du deine Rollanheber steuern.
Ohne, dass man denen ihren Hut braucht, oder dass man irgendwelche anderen Sachen braucht, rein offline.
Eigentlich ziemlich geil, dass das geht.
Ich würde halt keine Firmware-Updates machen, falls man da überhaupt Firmware-Updates machen kann.
Ich meine, warum nicht? Ich meine, man kann seine Zahnbürste Firmware upgraden, warum sollte man nicht auch einen Rollanheber Firmware upgraden können?
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich sie mir holen werd. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich schon für die Kampagne.
Nest, Alter, Nest, warum, warum Nest? Nest ist Seite Google-Übernahme, und dass du keinerlei Möglichkeiten mehr hast, das ordentlich zu integrieren, einfach nur Crap.
Oh nein. Gute, gute Idee, gute Idee.
Gute Idee, gute Idee. Das hab ich auch gemacht, oder will ich mal, ich bin noch nicht fertig, dass nicht die, was ich meine, nicht die Garage, sondern dass ich Notifications schicke, wenn Fenster vergessen wurden.
Ich hab halt noch nicht alle Fenster equipped mit Door-Sensor, die meisten schon, aber noch nicht alle.
Und das ist halt praktisch, wenn man dann rausgeht und vergesst ein Fenster zuzumachen, kriegst du eine Notification auf Smartphone, was sagt, ey Max, was vergesst, das Fenster oben im Bad zuzumachen.
GW-OZ-13-Kuschreinader, 13 Monate, das ist ja schon richtig Hypersubscription.
Hypersubs, Hypersubscriber. Eigentlich für den Sub. Massive exquisite big brain Sub.
Ja, das ist, das ist praktisch, aber halt nur, wenn man direkt von der Straße in die Garage fahren kann.
Was bringt dir eine Notification? Naja, ich geh einfach wieder rein und machs zu.
Ich hab das Handy dabei, geh aus der Haustür raus, das Ding stellt fest, aha, der Max geht jetzt.
Und dann krieg ich ne Message aufs Handy, du hast vergessen das Badfenster zuzumachen, dann dreh ich wieder um, geh rein, mach das Badfenster zu, geh wieder raus.
Ich mein, cool wär's, könnte das automatisch das Badfenster zu machen, aber das ist so ein bisschen kompliziert.
Chuck96, 15 Monate, jetzt gehen aber hier die, alles, die ganzen Hypersubscriber durch die Decke.
Verklickt. Eigentlich schon für den Sub.
Ah, yes, Kokona.
Die Kinder sind doch nicht blöd, die ihr wissen doch auch, der Vater hat das eingestellt, dass der Router ausgeht. Dann, dann sagen sie halt nicht, Papa gib das Tablet wieder, dann sagen sie Papa mach endlich Internet wieder an.
Ich glaube, das, das klingt nur in der Theorie gut.
Alter, wie es da halt.
Das hört sich ja an, wie als bist du irgendwie in der Kirche, das halt ja brutal. Na gut, da steht ja auch nichts rum, in dem Raum, das ist ja einfach nur Wand, ohne irgendwelche Möbel oder sonst was.
Pure Savage, drei Monate, exzellent. Nee, Moment, nicht Hypersubscriber, verklickt, normaler Subscriber, aber Prime-Subscriber.
Eigentlich schon. Der Scam Train ist am Start, ja, lasst euch mal Scam Trainen, Scamass Trainen.
Das ist Logitech-Gedönster, ja gut.
Deswegen mag ich Home Assistant, du hast ein Hub für alles. Bei ihm ist es ja so, er muss die Konfix machen in Alexa, er muss die Konfix machen in seinem Harmony-Hub, er muss die Konfix in seinen 20.000 verschiedenen Smart-Steckdosen, sonst was andere Dinge im Smartphone machen.
Deswegen ist so ein zentraler Hub wie Home Assistant wirklich sehr praktisch.
Kleiner Giotto, zwei Monate, dankeschön.
Die verwende ich auch, das ist genau die Fernbedienung, die drüben im Wohnzimmer auch im Einsatz ist. Die Firestick-Fernbedienung, allerdings verwende ich die mit dem Shield-TV.
Gute Idee, das ist eine gute Idee, das könnte ich auch machen. Aktuell habe ich es so, dass das ab 20 Uhr geschaltet wird, also 19 Uhr geht die Heizung im Wohnzimmer drüben an und das Licht geht um 20 Uhr an.
Aber das könnte ich auch machen, dass das alles geschaltet wird mit der Fernseh geht an, das ist eigentlich eine coole Sache. Gute Idee.
Wieso sieht das wie Android KitKat aus, weil es Android-TV ist?
Okay, das ist jetzt ziemlich sinnlos.
Okay, es wird erstmal hier Smart-Beleuchtung geflext.
Das ist cool, das ist cool, dann läufst du dann daran vorbei und es geht immer da wo du vorbei läufst, das Licht an, was allerdings ein bisschen doof ist, weil vielleicht fällt es euch auf, dass immer erst angeht das Licht, wenn er schon vorbei ist oder schon da ist.
Guck mal, der ist quasi schon da, also sprich das Licht geht jetzt da an, wo er gerade ist und nicht dort wo er hinläuft, das könnte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser teilen.
Gute Idee, das da hinten ist es auch angegangen. Aber guck hier, das ist jetzt nur angegangen, als er dran vorbei gelaufen ist.
Vielleicht müsste man den Motion Sensor ein bisschen weiter vorne hin machen, weil das Licht soll ja dort beleuchten wo du bist und vor allem dort wo du hingehst, weil ansonsten brauchst du ja auch kein Licht wenn du ins Dunkle läufst, wenn es nur da angeht wo du bist, wisst ihr was ich meine?
Das sieht richtig cool aus, ich würde zwar nicht im Leben auf die Idee kommen einen Schrank bei mir mit Smart Lighting zu versorgen, weil dann müsstest du ja wenn du mit einem Schrank anfängst, willst du dann letztendlich irgendwann alle Schränke haben, aber es sieht cool aus, es sieht echt cool aus. Guck mal, du gehst hier dran und dann fadeet auch noch das Licht so ein, das ist richtig cool gemacht.
Moment, es ist ohne Kabel, ohne Kabel ist schwierig, das ist dann musst du alle paar Monate aufladen. Kannst du im Serverraum bei mir machen? Ja könnte ich, allerdings im Serverraum habe ich einfach eine Lampe an der Decke.
Die einschalte, noch nicht mal mit, noch ganz oldschool mit Taster, nicht mal mit Motion Sensor.
Das ist praktisch, das ist eine Sache, das kann ich auch jedem empfehlen, dass es so ein Off Switch gibt.
Aktuell habe ich das zum selber drücken noch, aber ich habe mir die ganze Zeit schon überlegt, ob ich mir nicht unter das Bett so eine Matte mache oder unter die Matratze so eine kleine Matte mache, die erkennt, wenn man sich drauf legt und dann könnte man sagen, okay es ist nach 22 Uhr, 15 Minuten lang liegt der Typ jetzt schon drauf, der ist wohl ins Bett.
Und dann macht er alle Lichter aus, die ich vergessen habe und die Heizung runter, wo ich es vergessen habe und sowas, das ist wirklich etwas äußerst sinnvolles.
Richtig gutes Video, da waren wirklich ein paar sinnvolle Sachen dabei.
Gut Idee, so und jetzt, Chad meint, ich soll mir das noch angucken. Deswegen, unabhängig von Laser oder sonst was, deswegen kommt bei mir kein Smart Lock an die Eingangstür. Die Sache ist nämlich die, es gab so viele Sicherheitsprobleme, was Smart Locks angeht.
Das letzte an was ich mich erinnern kann, wo ich auch wieder echt nur den Kopf schütteln konnte, ist, dass man eine Handy App hatte für das Smart Lock. Ich frage mich nicht, welches Smart Lock das war, das habe ich nur bei Heize gelesen, also ich habe das Smart Lock nicht.
Zumindest habe ich gelesen, es gab eine Smart Lock mit einer Handy App, wo man Leute inviteen konnte, was ja an sich eine gute Idee ist.
Also sprich, ich invitee jetzt irgendeinen Freund oder so und dann kriegt er einen Invite Link und kann dann mit seinem Handy irgendwie meinen Schloss aufmachen. Was ich schonmal eigentlich nie machen würde, weil ich will nicht, dass der in mein Haus geht, wenn ich nicht da bin, aber es ist eine gute Idee.
So, das Problem dabei war nur, also allein schon Smart Lock mit Cloud ist halt so unfraglich, aber das Problem dabei war nur, dass der Invite Link, wenn man ein bisschen was erraten, war das das Nuki Smart Lock, kann durchaus sein, man konnte den Invite Link erraten.
Also sprich, man konnte sich selbst inviteen in andere Leute Häuser, ohne dass sie dich inviteen mussten. Und solche Sachen habe ich echt im Kopf geschüttelt, das ist halt einer der Gründe, dass ich keinen Smart Lock mir einbaue.
Weil letztendlich, selbst wenn ich die Config von irgendwas verkacke, was ich im Haus gebaut habe, da passiert nichts. Aber wenn man in irgendeiner Art und Weise die Haustür verkackt, ist halt Mist, ja.
War das User plus Datum, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Und das hier sollte ich mal auf Baukasten für professionelle Bastler. Exzellent.
Ne, das kenne ich nicht.
Aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal an. Breaking into Smart Home with a Laser.
Alter, will er jetzt erstmal alles triggern bei euch? Das ist ja fies. Bei wie viel ist jetzt was angegangen?
Ich wundere mich eh, dass es nicht mehr Trollvideos gibt in der Richtung, die einfach mal zwischendurch die ganzen Triggerwörter sagen.
Hallo Magenta.
You have a microphone listening to you in the room right now. What I just did probably worked to a small percentage of you. That is terrifying.
Es gab doch mal diese Burger King Werbung, die bei Burger King über Alexa was bestellt hat.
Die hat übelst viel Hass auf sich gezogen.
Warte mal, wo gibt's?
Hallo.
Burger King. Fresh Ingredients is in the Whopper Sandwich.
Ja.
Okay.
Hallo.
Ja.
Ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, ne? Aber das hat übelst viel Hate auf sich gezogen.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ja, Breaking. Ja, da.
Okay, wir müssen hier spulen mal ein bisschen vor, das ist ein bisschen lang.
Ja, ist alles Crap. Smartlocks, alles Müll, kommt bei mir echt nicht. Also nicht an die Haustür, im Haus vielleicht, aber nicht an die Haustür.
Okay, ich will mir nicht das ganze Video jetzt angucken.
Okay.
Okay, Champ.
Hä?
Was gibt das, wenn's fertig ist?
Ich glaube, das Video müsste man sich komplett angucken, dass man checkt, was sie da machen, aber ich hab ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock mehr, komplett dazu zu gucken.
Sie aktivieren mit dem Laser das Mikrofon, okay? Und dann sagen sie ihr was, oder?
Äh, Moment, Leute, kennt ihr diese Steckdosen? Kommen euch die Steckdosen irgendwie bekannt vor? Nur mal so, habt ihr die schon irgendwo gesehen?
Vielleicht gestern bei mir im Stream? Das sind die gleichen Steckdosen, die wir gestern im Stream hatten. Die hier.
Äh, ja, ihr wisst, was ich mein.
Die hier. Nur, dass die die Ami-Variante haben und wir die EU-Variante.
Was grob gesagt, richten die den Laser auf das Mikro und modulieren über Impulse den Sprach, bevor der dann Schlüssel öffnet.
Exzellent. Das ist, das ist mal hier Big Brain. Aber guck mal, das ist das gleiche, die gleiche Steckdose, die wir gestern auch hatten. Nur die Ami, nur die Ami-Variante.
Okay, gut. Was gucken wir denn, was gucken wir denn jetzt?
Lego Pizza Factory. Ach, ich krieg schon Hunger. Ich krieg langsam Hunger. Also das könnte man sich jetzt tatsächlich noch mal geben.
Lego Pizza Factory. Yes.
Moment, wie will der das denn? Der Lego schmilzt im Ofen.
Oh, jetzt wird's aber advanced.
Erstmal Tomaten-Sauce. Oh, ich will's nicht sauber machen müssen danach, ey.
Das gibt, oh, das gibt Sauerei.
Ultrafette Pizza.
Die Idee ist cool.
Schmier, schmier, schmier.
Drei Stunden später.
Nee, es ist komplett unsinnig. Ich find die Idee, wie alles, also die ganzen Videos von ihm, find ich die Idee immer ziemlich geil, aber es ist halt komplett unsinnig.
Bäh, guck mal, wie hier die Sauce reingeht, ey.
Es ist, es ist, es ist sehr gleichmäßig, sehr gleichmäßig verteilt, ja.
Jetzt erst mal Käse drauf geschmissen, wo die Hälfte wieder vorbeifällt.
Ja, ich glaub's sollte nicht gut, also die Pizza ist viel zu fett. Also der Teig ist viel zu dick. Ich glaube aber, das schmeckt, also die Pizza schmeckt glaube ich nicht gut.
Industrie 4.0.
Und Pepperoni-Wurst-Scheiben. Oha, gleich fällt's runter.
Das wäre ein Video für dich, können wir gleich vielleicht mal gucken.
Ich krieg übelst Hunger, nicht wegen der Pizza, sondern weil's gleich 12 ist und ich irgendwie Hunger krieg.
Das ist nicht so, dass es so wahnsinnig appetitanregend aussieht, dass ich davon als großer Hunger krieg.
Tiefkühl-Pizza wird, ähm, ja wahrscheinlich nicht besser zubereitet, aber definitiv schneller und gleichmäßiger zubereitet als das hier.
Was gibt das, wenn's fertig ist? Ah, Würstchen.
Ach nee, das ist das Ding, was die Pepperoni-Wurst-Scheiben verteilt.
Exzellent.
Was kommt jetzt?
Ein bisschen Paprika in den Sock.
Das ist komplett useless.
Und jetzt in den Ofen, mit Lego.
Ohne Lego.
Oh, guck mal, hier sogar mit Schnibbel. Pizza-Schnibbler.
Oh nee, der Schnitt, da tut ja weh. So stumpf, wie das Ding ist.
Und es ist kalt, nachdem er fertig geschnitten hat.
Ob das überhaupt richtig durch ist, frage ich mich, weil das hat auch gar keinen ordentlichen Druck drauf.
Wahrscheinlich schneidet das gar nicht richtig. Muss wahrscheinlich noch zur Hälfte auseinanderreißen.
Ich weiß nicht, meinte das hat wirklich so sauber geschnitten, das Lego-Ding? Also sauber und so durch?
Oh man, aber exzellent Idee wieder.
Save nachgeschnitten wahrscheinlich. So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Davon haben wir schon ein paar Sachen geguckt.
Was grills in der IT? Das ist fake, das Video, das glaube ich nicht.
Muss fake sein.
Moment, das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Network-Tour?
Aber von denen haben wir schon ein paar Videos geguckt, die fand ich immer ganz gut gemacht.
Also was hier? Day in the life of a data center. Moment, haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Moment, das sind die zwei Dudes, das haben wir doch schon geguckt, oder?
Ah, gut, der RZ-Sound. Der richtig echte. Exzellent.
Nee, das haben wir noch nicht geguckt. Die Dudes haben wir schon geguckt, aber nicht das Video.
Hast du Lust meine Webseite on stream zu bewerten?
Bewerten inwiefern auf was?
Die haben ihre Ohr-Protection alle so richtig an.
Das sieht nicht so gut aus, oder?
Das sieht man schon mal, dass das ein Werbevideo ist, weil normalerweise nehmen das die Leute nicht so ernst, was Gehörschutz angeht im RZ.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich gehe auch meistens komplett ohne Gehörschutz rein und wenn ich da länger als 10 Minuten mal drin sein muss, dann gehe ich schnell vor und hole mir noch einen Gehörschutz.
Wir sind oben. Wir machen erst die Räder.
Hallo!
Wir haben gerade besprochen, dass wir die Räder zuerst aufsetzen, damit sie in der richtigen Position sind.
Was ich hier beobachte...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es seht, aber auf der Räder ist die Position gelabelt.
Das ist die gleiche, wie die, die wir gerade in die Räder gesetzt haben.
Die haben sogar Handschuhe an. Nee, Leute. Handschuhe und Anti-Static-Bändchen. Das muss ein Werbevideo sein. Das machen bestimmt welche. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, das macht keiner, aber ich habe es bisher selten gesehen.
Die Seite ist da drüben. Meine Seite ist hier drüben. Jetzt können wir es sicherlich zurückpushen.
Das ist das Nutella. Ich würde sagen, die.
Manchmal sehen auch die Lüfter falsch rum.
Das ist definitiv eine HP-Kiste. Man muss sagen, dass die Serverhersteller es besser schaffen, so eine Identität an Optik im Serverbereich zu haben, dass man sofort erkennt, welcher Hersteller was ist.
Besser als im Desktopbereich. Ich kann dir im Serverbereich sofort sagen, ob es Dell HP oder IBM ist, bzw. Lenovo.
Siehst du sofort. Dell ist eher silber-grau durchgängig vorne. HP ist grau mit diesem schwarz-rot. IBM ist komplett schwarz mit teilweise ein bisschen silbernden Aufdrucken.
Man erkennt das schon. Manchmal ein bisschen blauer Schrift, je nachdem. Man erkennt das ziemlich gut verwalten, welcher Serverhersteller es ist.
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch nicht viele. Das war es ja mehr oder weniger. Dell HP Lenovo.
Und klar gibt es theoretisch noch andere, aber was gibt es sonst noch großartig verbreitet? Also Netzwerk-Hardware außen vor. Was gibt es sonst noch großartiges? Dell HP IBM. Was hat man sonst noch großartig? Nix, oder?
Super Micro. Ja, jetzt vielleicht im kleineren Bereich, aber so wirklich in großem Ersatz. Es ist eigentlich so gut wie IBM, Lenovo, HP und Dell. Fujitsu hatte ich noch nie in der Hand.
Eraser mit RGB, genau. Cisco Plates. Stimmt, die haben wir mal getestet vor Jahren und haben sie nämlich nicht verwendet. Ok, das Video ist nicht so spannend.
Man muss den aber echt so gut halten, die machen das mit den Kabel immer sehr ordentlich. Nicht so spannend diesmal. So, was machen sie hier?
Ja, gut, das ist ziemlich standard, dass man so doppelten Boden hat, wo Zeug drin ist. Das ist bei uns auch so.
Ich vermute mal, dass es für irgendwelche Glasfasergedöns ist, weil man da nicht reingucken soll, oder?
Also solltet ihr mal in einem RZ irgendwie eine Glasfaserkabel in der Hand halten. Guckt nicht rein. Je nachdem, was das für ein Laser ist, oder was da für Sachen durchgehen, ist das für euer Auge nicht gut.
Ordentliche, was ist wahrscheinlich, irgendwelche Fiber Channel Geschichten, Glasfasergedöns, Switcher, Patch Panels, man erkennt es jetzt nicht so genau.
Das sind irgendwelche KVM. Nee, sind das KVM? Nee, sind das nicht. Das sind auch Glasfaser. Die haben ziemlich viel Glasfasergedöns.
Ja gut, so sieht das normalerweise aus, dass du die Kabel so überm Kopf hängen hast. Das ist bei uns auch so. Das ist glaube ich bei den meisten so.
Dass du hier oben so paar Schienen hast, wo der ganze Kram lang geht. Was witzig ist, wenn du Verbindungen suchen musst und die nicht ordentlich beschrieben sind.
Das ist geil, weil meistens ist es ja so, dass der Server, der hier oben drin steht, an dem Switch rankommt, der hier irgendwo hinten steht.
Das heißt, es geht dann vom Server hoch an Switch, vom Switch dann hier oben drüber, oder vielleicht sogar direkt vom Server an, wenn man ein bisschen Geld sparen wollte, hier oben drüber, dann vorne hin.
Und wir haben uns da teilweise echt kaputt gesucht früher, nach Verbindungen, wenn die nicht ordentlich beschriftet waren. Und bei uns war kaum eine Verbindung ordentlich beschriftet.
Okay, das ist jetzt nicht so spannend.
Okay, Netzwerk, Netzwerke, Dolns.
Ah ne, nicht so spannend diesmal.
Ja, Epiprinter ist bei uns auch so. Mittlerweile geht's, mittlerweile geht's wirklich.
Aber als ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet hab, also dort, wo wir noch im anderen Rechenzentrum waren, da war es komplett random, also manche Sachen waren beschriftet.
Meine Trinkkanne ist kaputt. Manche Sachen waren beschriftet, aber das meiste nicht.
Ja, und wir haben es auch schon mal geschafft, was kaputt zu machen, rein durch Kabelwechsel. Obwohl wir, das war ich sogar mit Felix zusammen damals noch, mit Felix haben wir das zusammen gemacht.
Mit dem hab ich mal Vorurzeiten auf deine Gamescom Video aufgenommen. Und da sollten wir irgendwelche ESX-Surfer umpatchen.
Haben wir auch richtig gemacht. Das Problem war nur, dass irgendeine Fiber-Anbindung an irgendwelche Sahnen-Gedöns hat einen Wackelkontakt gehabt oder war kaputt oder was auch immer.
Und wir haben beim Rausziehen der Kabel das irgendwie dazu gebracht, dass der Switch gemeint hat, sein Partnerswitch wäre kaputt und hat alles umgeschaltet.
Das hat irgendwie eine halbe Stunde geruckelt und es ging nichts mehr. Kann man passieren, ja. Aber da konnten wir eh nix für.
kann man passieren aber da konnten wir nix für ja ich weiß wenn dann erstmal so 2000
switcher anfangen spending tree neu aufzubauen oder solche dinge dann dann ruckelt halt auch
mal kurz dieser gaming pc startet mit 75 euro ok was haben wir sonst noch zu gucken
das ist wahrscheinlich was wo ich absolut nicht zustimmen würde weil windows 7 in 2020 zu
verwenden es ist nicht so fahrlässig wie windows xp aber windows 7 hat jetzt auch kein support
mehr würde ich nicht machen also ich weiß sagt der richtige gibt ja genug leute die sich dann bei
mir auf youtube immer möchte man seine stimme ist so scheiße ist das windows 8 das windows 8
ok ok jetzt kommt die erklärung windows 10 ist bad da bin ich ja mal gespannt ich
meine ich finde auch vieles ziemlich kacke an windows aber das ist nicht unbedingt
windows 10 spezifisch also jetzt mittlerweile schon aber vieles war da schon immer so
ok da hat er recht das audio von dem video das kann ich mir nicht geben ja das ist kacke
das ist das das finde ich auch beschissen das stimmt schon das ist hat er recht hat er recht
dass das settings menü ist auch für den arsch allerdings darf man sich da nichts nix in so
weit falls vormachen also das war unter windows 7 jetzt auch nicht der weisheitsletzter schluss
und vor allem hast du eben das problem dass windows 7 nicht mehr support ist das heißt
unabhängig davon ob dir vielleicht das ui ein bisschen besser gefällt oder nicht du
kriegst keine ordentlichen patches mehr für windows 7 ja windows door sagt ok er findet
windows 10 scheiße das habe ich verstanden also es gibt ja schon ein ko kriterium ohne
aktuelle security updates ist es scheiß egal ob windows 7 eben von der oberfläche her besser
gefällt du hast das problem du kriegst keine aktuellen sicherheits updates das sagt schon
mal und neue sachen wird es da auch nicht geben also sollte es mal eine neue x version geben
wird sie nicht für wenn noch sieben geben sollte es irgendwelche anderen features wird
es das nicht für wenn noch sieben geben also allein schon aus dem grund mag ihm vielleicht
wenn noch sieben von der oberfläche besser gefallen aber besser im eigentlichen sinne
das ist jetzt das sinnvollere system ist 2020 zu benutzen ist es auf jeden fall nicht und
ich habe versucht das audio geht das audio ist ok mal was sagt er zu security da bin
ich mal gespannt weil sie gut ist ja der hauptsächliche grund warum man das nicht verwenden sollte
im i worried about my security no natürlich war es könnte auch nicht erklären warum
was verwendet i made a windows 7 survival guide video back when windows 7 ended support explaining
ways you can keep yourself secure after 2020 but i'll simplify my points what browsers
are still up to date and how viruses are still up to date the majority of other programs are
still up to date and we have brains nine die meisten leute haben kein brain also das ist
ja mal eine steile these windows update is not only just one layer of security but it's
honestly the last layer of security because all the other factors i just mentioned basically
supplement this lack of security updates and they're the first layers that viruses go through
before they get to windows update nein also je nachdem was es ist absolut gar nicht gehen
wir mal von irgendwelchen melddown geschichten aus von irgendwelchen ssl fehlen oder sonst was wenn
das nicht eine reine browser implementierung ist und auf windows sachen zurückgreift dann ist das hat
das nichts damit zu tun dass da irgendwie da chrome aktuell ist na klar browser sind sage ich auch immer
browser sind die hauptsächlich in sachen die die die gefährdet sind ja aber das andere ist nicht
unwichtig und windows itself and besides this operating system was last updated in january of
2020 unless we were in the early 2010s or the late 2000s most vulnerabilities at this point have
been found and currently nein wie der will auch nicht ernsthaft erzählen dass die meisten die
meisten schwachstellen von windows mittlerweile gefunden sind garantiert nicht das schwachsinn
totaler blödsinn wirklich das ist wirklich schwachsinnig es können auch alle möglichen
hier basti ich wollte es gerade sagen es könnten auch irgendwelche unsinnigen treiber sein was
plutus angeht was wlan angeht was usb angeht oder sonst was also das ist also das ist das blödsinn
und auf die frage im chat wie wichtig sind sicherheits abseits wenn man nicht speziell das macht
allein schon wenn du ins internet gehst willst du aktuelle sicherheits abseits haben natürlich
ist es wichtig dass dein browser aktuell ist ja aber gerade bei sachen wo irgendwie auf
betriebssystem sachen zugegriffen wird sei es keine ahnung screenshots screensharing irgendwelche
ssl geschichten sonst was also browser interagieren ja schon auf mehreren eben im betriebssystem wenn
dort outdated sachen verwendet werden kann das auch zu problemen führen obwohl der browser aktuell
ist kannst die kommentare mal lesen ja ok die bewertung warum hat das 4000 daumen hoch das
ist kompletter stumpfsinn people are mad at me because of linux was
das lohnt sich nicht anzugucken
genau samba lücke und also das ist komplett bescheuert zu sagen hey hauptsache der browser
ist aktuell da kannst du auch klein windows na gut ne xp gibt es kein aktuellen firefox
mehr für das ist blödsinnig ok was haben wir hier dieser gaming pc startet mit 75 euro
startet was heißt das der pc boot nachdem er hat wer mit 75 euro investiert hat oder
ist es eine auktion die mit 75 euro startet man weiß es nicht
einige fahrstühle laufen auch noch mit windows 7 ja es gibt auch viele bankautomaten die mit
windows xp laufen übrigens die rmv bank die die rmv ticketautomaten laufen raspberry pi aber das
ist nicht so wild weil die dinge hängen ja nicht im internet dann fahrstuhl sollte nicht über das
internet erreichbar sein es gibt bestimmt genug fahrstühle die über das internet erreichbar sind
es gibt ja auch ganze kraftwerke die teilweise über das internet erreichbar sind oder solche
sachen aber wenn das normal sinnvoll gemacht ist dann sollten die nicht über das internet
erreichbar sein oder generell eigentlich über nichts außer vielleicht eine serielle schnittstelle
eine usb oder sonst was dann ist das nicht so wild weil wie sollst du dran kommen
ja und herzlich willkommen zurück zu einem neuen video von mir heute bauen wir ein gaming pc
zusammen ich mache es jetzt nicht mal 75 euro ich habe ein gaming pc für den und den preis
zusammengebaut sondern ich fange jetzt mit 75 euro an ich habe bei ebay kleinanzeigen nämlich
ein angebot gefunden für mainboard cpu kühler ebenso ein dreckiges gehäuse und so das möchten
wir gleich abholen und ja dann besorge ich noch nach und nach teile dafür tatsächlich und wenn
dann irgendwas später nicht die hare sehen irgendwie so oder wenn irgendwer sagt ja bau
das und das ein so gewuschelt aus vielleicht noch nicht ich weiß es noch nicht das kommt aus
schüttorf und ok das ist wieder die gleiche taktik könnt ihr euch noch an diesen 0 euro pc
erinnern 0 euro pc genau 0 euro pc und dann erstmal 50 euro hin und her gefahren würde ich
dann jetzt sofort abholen und nun bin ich wieder zu hause exzellent wie man unschwer erkennen kann
und das war wirklich eine sehr entspannte fahrt also ich war schon lange nicht mehr so entspannt
bei der autofahrt das ist gut zu wissen gut zu wissen nur ich die straße mein auto und gute
musik ich habe auf meinem zweitkanal mal einen lofi house mix gemacht da waren auch zwei drei
lieder davon dabei das war wirklich oberklasse alles klar ich bin sehr tiefen entspannt und das
ist jetzt wissen wir bescheid ist super entspannt exzellent ich habe ihr einmal die teile hingelegt
und zeigt sie euch einmal ob sie dann tatsächlich funktionieren das weiß man nicht und wäre
vielleicht auch zu in frage zu stellen bei der lagerung aber wenn wir morgen rausfinden habe
ich morgen noch ein bisschen überraschung übrig so quasi die teile liegen jetzt so vor mir zur
erinnerung ich habe 75 euro bezahlt wir beginnen einfach mal mit der grafikkarte das ist eine
gtx 960 gamer kf a 2 o c platinum 960 ok das ist noch nicht uralt das ist nur zwei generationen alt
bimmel bammel edition auf jeden fall vier gigabyte grafikspeicher scheint nicht allzu schlecht zu
sein ich hatte nämlich auf den bildern tatsächlich gelesen dass eine gtx 950 ist also hast du auch
wieder werbung bei twitch ich habe die ganze zeit werbung bei twitch kühler der vorbesitzer also
schon seit einem monat oder so seitdem seitdem es über jubel nicht mal richtig funktioniert war
so lieb und hat natürlich auch dieses label darauf gelassen damit ich den kühler natürlich
auch komplett wie neu verwenden kann ich denke er mochte den pc nicht sehr weil er immer laut
war oder die cpu immer runter getaktet hat weil sich durch so eine folie die wärme bekanntermaßen
nicht allzu moment er hat die folie drauf gelassen und hat das hat moment das habe ich das
richtig verstanden der ursprüngliche besitzer hat diesen cpu lüfter auf den auf die cpu durch
die folie gemacht oder ich sage ja immer dass man mittlerweile kaum was falsch machen kann
beim pc zusammen bauen aber ich werde immer eines besseren belehrt man kann doch jede menge
falsch machen optimal überträgt seht ihr hier die hito pepos kommen drei hito pepos ich musste
mehrmals nachfragen wirklich alles zu kriegen was auf den bildern zu sehen war weil der eigentliche
vorkäufer ich glaube der sohn der eltern logischerweise nicht zu hause war weil ich ja eher
da war und naja den kühler musste ich nachfragen den karton hier mit den schrauben mit den
befestigungen festplatte das ist die watschbauanleitung ja genauso sieht es aus da hingestellt bekommen das
gehäuse davon war nicht die rede gewesen wobei lauter watschbauanleitung muss man den cpu kühler
als allerletztes rein machen sehr sinnvoll ist irgendeins von schakuen hier meine tastatur von
skiller dies allerdings ein bisschen dreckig hier fehlt das skiller tastatur einfach karton das
letzte mal hat er auch den die ports mit einem stück karton abgedeckt wenn man so low end sachen
macht ist es gar nicht schlecht vielleicht neues plexiglas rein oder gitter davor was weiß ich dazu
gibt es noch vier gigabyte ddr 3 ram 1600 megahertz einen lüfter und ein paar abgeschnittene kabel
abgeschnitten deswegen weiß ich nicht keine ahnung auf jeden fall die usb anschlüsse vielleicht war
sie zu laut oder hat einfach den lüfter abgeschnitten anstatt auszustecken die fehlen oder die sind dann
jetzt nicht mehr zu gebrauchen weil das glaube ich ein bisschen viel löterarbeit ist aber hier die
sechs kabel die könnte man zur not noch eben dran packen mainboard ist ein b 85 m pro 4 mit einem
i5 4 4 6 0 ich hatte auf dem bild erst das ist gar nicht so übel das ist nur keine ahnung nur so
sechs jahre alt fünf jahre alt ja sechs jahre alt
4 4 4 0 gelesen aber der ist dann noch mal ein stück besser hier ist wärmeleitpaste
darauf verteilt das bord ist sehr sehr dreckig sehr sehr sehr dreckig das stört das bord ja
nicht bord aber extrem verbogen ist nicht kann man das so sehen auch hier die hier nach außen
gebogen hier oben also mir wurde gesagt der bruder hätte das irgendwie zusammengebaut also
kein richtiger profi am werk zusammenbau oder jetzt beim auseinanderbau und irgendwie zerfletzt
hier das weiß man noch nicht und dazu gab es noch ein cooler master g 450 ok zumindest schon
einmal schon einmal kein lc power die chance dass es nicht gleich abfackel ist schon mal gegeben
also lc power ist echt das schlimmste china billignetzteile und so weiter waren dabei ein
atx stromstecker haben wir hier für eine grafikkarte jeweils 28 fins ja und noch ein abgeschnittenes
kabel ich werde diesen abend nicht mehr testen ich werde jetzt glaube ich schlafen gehen und
kann glaube ich sehr sehr gut schlafen da fällt mir gerade auf die tastatur ist hier kaputt also
die kann man nicht mehr verkaufen höchstens noch mit verschenken und dafür mache ich sie jetzt
glaube ich nicht sauber die kommt direkt in möli nur dieses kleine teil habe ich immer jemand
netzteil angeschlossen da vorne also auch nichts besonderes in der in diesem bereich und dazu gab
es noch hier diese wundervolle wohlwort tüte unbedingt die brauchbar ja und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen video sekunde oder video minute vielleicht passt das ja auf die minute genau kann
man nicht wissen es ist der nächste tag ich habe wieder keine zeit dazu aber ich möchte es mir
auf jeden fall nicht nehmen das nehmen lassen die teile einmal zu testen und aus diesem grund
tue ich das einfach mal ich habe jetzt mal nicht das cooler master das cooler master netzteil hier
angeklemmt das also das wird wohl vernünftig sein aber irgendwie ist ein bisschen leicht für
ein netzteil guck dir das an jetzt blutet das hier muskierer nachher pusten da fahre ich
nämlich gleich noch hin cpu habe ich draufgepackt inklusive diesem einen arbeitsspeicher in den
ersten slot wie es sich gehört dann einmal mit einer zahnbürste ein zwei mal durch noch durch
gepustet damit ich habe noch nie mit einer zahnbürste meine ram slots ausgeputzt eigentlich eine gute
idee aber ich hatte bisher noch nicht das bedürfnis dazu man da kontaktprobleme ausschließen kann
genau so du kannst dich nicht vernünftig drehen das ist ja gar nicht so schlimm kühler ist auch
einigermaßen befestigt ich will ihn jetzt nur kurz starten ohne jetzt großartig tests anzustellen
ach ja ich habe das hier vorhin im chat gar nicht gelesen irgendjemand hat auch geschrieben dass
er sich das gleiche singtb thermostat gekauft hat wie ich na und ich hatte gefragt ob der knopf bei
dem auch so schwerfällig ist also falls der noch da ist wird mit das wird mich immer noch
interessieren ich habe die antwort nicht gelesen vorhin falls du was geschrieben hast
habe ich extra dran gepackt damit wir vielleicht gleich sehen ob etwas wahrscheinlich auch neue
des meister ja wir kriegen schon ein bild aber ich habe halt auch bei mir alter hat wer so ist es
nicht und ich habe die noch nie sauber gemacht ich puste dann immer sauge vielleicht mal ein gutes
das ist ja schon mal sehr gut möchte überhaupt so ein mainboard an wert um die 30 das ist box
lüfter das ziemlich sicher die kabel ist der inter box lüfter 40 bis 50 so ungefähr aus dem
kopf manchmal teurer manchmal billiger das ist schon mal sehr gut und dann können wir ja mal
nachdem ich allerdings einmal im kontaktproblem vorzubeugen die zahnbürste wieder durchgegangen
bin die grafikkarte testen wirklich nur ein zweimal durchgehen das ist ja elektrostatisch
aufladbar und so kann man etwas kaputt machen grafikkarte ist drauf klemper nur deswegen muss
man sich dieses tolle armband anziehen wo jeder sagt es ist richtig nice wenn man so ein armband
hat aber nie jemand ein armband anzieht sich sauber machen demnächst noch wunderschönes logo ich habe
mal die festplatte die dabei war angeklemmt vielleicht hat er da ja sogar windows drauf
installiert würde ich erstmal die private die private pons runterziehen nicht unbedingt
empfehlen aber man kann es machen und wenn man irgendwas machen kann wie zum beispiel auch hier
die folie dran lassen dann macht man das auch gelegentlich ob bewusst oder unbewusst ist dann
erst mal egal es gibt zumindest schon mal ein bild ne windows normal starten aber man starten
kann erst mal mit tastatur dran exzellent wahrscheinlich boot jetzt nicht doch ich weiß
nicht aber ich glaube dass den kommt aus so einem ich hatte mal genau die gleiche festplatte in so
einem lenovo laptop habe ich vom trödel markt mal für 9 euro oder so gekauft und da war genau die
gleiche festplatte drin steht auch lenovo part number und da war auf jeden fall fru die fru nummer
ist das die sagen umwobene fru nummer zumindest heißt das bei IBM server komponenten war das
früher immer die fru nummer mal in abgesicherten modus gehen ich denke nicht dass das klappt
läuft nicht aber ist ja auch egal die wird geschreddert die daten da drauf wenn die platte
doch in ordnung ist dann kann man sie für später vielleicht mal einsetzen aber das sieht zumindest
erst mal gut aus dass ich glaube das erste was ich machen würde wenn ich einen rechner gebraucht
kaufen würde das erste ist ich mache ein usb stick dran mit ihrem live linux und guckt mich ein
bisschen auf der festplatte um von demjenigen das vorher gehört hat dem vorher gehört hat
einfach weil ich neugierig bin was da war also ich weiß wenn die leute so blöd sind die den kram
sich löschen ja also ich ich wäre neugierig und ich werde es nicht jetzt sauber machen aber
irgendwann in ferner zukunft aus diesem grunde würde ich jetzt veranschlagen dass ich sage ja
wir machen das ding jetzt sauber und das machen wir irgendwann später aber ja und dann und alle
die jetzt sagen sie machen es nicht machen es doch wo heuse aussieht würde jeder mal drauf
gucken stell ich dafür auch eins weiß ich noch nicht da ist das irgendwie
irgendwie das lösungsmittel oder ist es einfach nur druckluft
hörwing vier monat dankeschön exquisite ackermans subscription atomfeed drei monat
dankeschön für den sub schon sehr viel besser jetzt mag man den kram auch wieder anfassen es
ist leider noch so ok sie deutlich sauberer aus ja es hat sich über die zeit nicht wieder gelegt
ich weiß nicht wie man das hinbekommt wahrscheinlich einen abstandshalter vergessen oder keine ahnung wenn
jemand etwas dazu weiß lassen nicht mal bitte wissen ich muss dazu sagen dass es jetzt knapp
ein monat später ist nachdem ich es abgeholt habe und getestet so lang weil ich einfach dachte ok
wir warten auf den richtigen moment weil ich mich da wirklich sehr darauf gefreut habe irgendwie
dieses video zu machen ja wie man sieht der arbeitsspeicher fehlt jetzt einer davon war
vormals dort drin und ich habe den noch noch dreimal den gleichen das heißt wir haben dann
zwölf gigabyte ram kann ich auch später auf 16 gigabyte ram aufrüsten wenn es mir nicht reicht
da habe ich auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen was das kann man dann dementsprechend ausprobieren
ich würde behaupten diese 160 gigabyte hdd von western digital ist nicht übermäßig schnell
damit kann man zwar anfangen ein paar spiele drauf packen aber ich baue dort diese 120 gigabyte ssd
ein die habe ich für 18 euro mit versand über ebay klein anzeigen vor ein paar tagen per post
erhalten das nehme ich immer praktisch bei ssd ist die kannst du auch per brief verschicken dann
kostet der versand auch keine minimal vier euro oder so sondern ich hoffe dass es bis zu weihnachten
oder nächstes jahr wenn ich mir neuen rechner kaufen will hoffe ich ja dass es wirklich sinnvoll
vier terabyte ssd gibt es gibt ja jetzt schon welche zum beispiel diese die von samsung die
kosten an 700 euro oder so acht terabyte meine ich ja also vier deswegen meine ich vier terabyte
wird mir reichen acht terabyte ssd ist aber das sind halt kuvo es ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
schlimm aber es wäre schon cool wenn es da jetzt da andere gebe
weil hier kostet das gleiche für vier terabyte so und und was ich halt mich fragen ist wann gibt
es vier terabyte nvme so das ist eigentlich das worauf ich warte und am liebsten von samsung ich
will diese komischen dinge hier nicht unbedingt haben genau und die haben doch keine ich hoffe
die schaffen es bei samsung bis ende des jahres oder anfang nächsten jahres vier terabyte m2
rauszubringen ich ich ich war kurz davor mir die acht terabyte ssd zu bestellen leute aber die
sache ist die ich habe schon mal den fehler gemacht vor ein paar jahren da habe ich mir auch so was
hier quasi gekauft also hier quasi für so ungefähr so viel oder ein bisschen bisschen weniger ssd und
damals waren halt zwei terabyte ssd ist total neu und der shit da habe ich mir für keine ahnung
56 euro oder so damals in zwei terabyte ssd gekauft und eineinhalb jahre später hat es irgendwie
noch ein drittel gekostet das mache ich nie wieder so um ein zwei euro geht es mir eigentlich nicht
aber vor allem wenn es darum geht ein paar mehr ssd sich irgendwo zu besorgen dann kann man das
glaube ich ganz gut machen zudem habe ich dann was hat er erzählt war ich baue dort diese 120
gigabyte ssd ein die habe ich für 18 euro mit versand über ebay klein anzeigen vor ein paar
tagen per post erhalten das nämlich immer praktisch bei ssd sie kann es auch per brief
verschicken dann kostet der versand auch keine minimal vier euro oder so sondern 1,90 oder so
keine ahnung so einfach alles bei aliexpress bestellen bei aliexpress kostet der versand teilweise
gar nichts oder 70 cent aus china oder eigentlich nicht aber vor allem wenn es darum geht ein paar
mehr ssd sich irgendwo zu besorgen also ich habe gesagt china ich habe ja letzten auf twitter
gelernt wenn man sagt dass in china chinesen wohnen ist das hardcore rassistisch das darf man ja
schon gar nicht mehr sagen ich ganz gut machen zudem habe ich dann gesehen dass dieser lüfter
noch vier leds eingebaut hat ich frage mich welche beleuchtung das oder welche farbe das dann sein
wird aber ja nun gut als festplatte extra für spiele chat war doch letztens ich habe letztens
geschrieben dass irgend ein chinesen eine made in china china steckdosen leiste designed hat
da haben sich leute auf twitter aufgeregt ich würde quasi den die die qualität der arbeit ich
würde irgendwie den chinesen abbrechen absprechen sie würden qualitative arbeit erledigen können
und das wäre irgendwie voll rassistisch dass ich geschrieben hätte nennt chinesen bei einer
made in china steckdose alter twitter die haben echt probleme werde ich glaube ich jetzt einfach
mal zu ein paar laptop festplatten greifen ich habe eine ganze menge gedacht von mal getestet
mir einfach die smartwerte anzeigen lassen und diesen eigentlich immerhin es könnte sein es
könnte sein es ist nicht es ist nicht ausgeschlossen vielleicht war das auch ein brasilianer der die
china steckdosen leiste designt hat ausgeschlossen ist das nicht teils alle in ordnung ich schaue mal
welche davon halbwegs schnell ist ansonsten kann man wenn man davon jetzt nicht gerade sorry
vielleicht war es eine brasilianerin ein brasilianer oder eine brasilianerin man weiß ja nie
zumal 500 gigabyte dreieinhalb zoll festplatte verwenden oder auch anderer größe hier steht
sogar darauf dass das spiele drauf sind da bräuchte auch nicht erneut runterladen das
ist schon mal ganz genau ja memory mann das auch geil gewesen wie sich auf twitter aufgeregt
haben als ich mir klopapier bestellt habe und das beste war ja dass ich sogar noch recht hatte
damit mit dem klopapier bestellen weil es war so klar dass alle wieder rum heulen dass im
geschäft nichts kriegen und die konnten einfach nicht so weit denken wie wir bestellen klopapier
einfach online ich habe einfach klopapier online bestellt und habe jetzt erstmal genug klopapier
und alle leute haben rumgeheult nach dem mond oh mein gott wir haben kein klopapier im geschäft
gibt es kein klopapier mehr also so schlimm einfach klopapier online bestellt aber ich
meine wir sind halt in deutschland 2020 online bestellen ist noch nicht bei allen leuten im
kopf angekommen damals oder jetzt ich meine man kann jetzt bei amazon immer noch klopapier
bestellen wenn man will mit zwei wochen lieferzeit wie viele packungen hast du noch ich habe ich
habe das ich habe ich habe gestern mal nachgezählt nicht glaube ich habe noch 68 rollen weil ich
habe dann gar gar nichts mehr davon weiterverwendet sondern habe ganz normal weiter klopapier gekauft
für den fall der fälle der jetzt eventuell eintritt dass man wieder nix bekommt ja aber
man kriegt man kriegt noch bei amazon und so kriegt man noch oh what the fuck also gestern gab es noch
ja doch gibt es noch aber ansonsten kann ich euch empfehlen geht auf
irgendeinen großhändler oder so und bestellt euch da einfach mal einen größeren packen klopapier
lieferwein 1 2 werktagen zack also man muss einfach mal ein bisschen mitdenken anstatt
die ganzen tag auf twitter rum zu heulen das ist ja das problem das ist ja das größte problem was
die ganze twitter army hat die twitter army ist den ganzen tag nur am rumheulen auf twitter anstatt
sich einfach mal ein bisschen gedanken zu machen kam bei dir nie an ok letztes mal oder jetzt also
bei mir kam es an toilettenpapier ist für den arsch ja das ist richtig wobei man es auch für
andere stellen verwenden kann ein gehäuse lüfter das sind die überreste vom alten gehäuse das alte
gehäuse habe ich ja für ein anderes video verwendet in gaming pc um 200 euro oder so
ja und ich wollte eben nicht all diese kabel neu anlöten aber erfreulicherweise hat sich ein
zuschauer bei mir gemeldet der meinte er hätte diese kabel komplett und würde sie mir zuschicken
wollen habe ich gesagt nee hör mal schickt das mal bitte dem nachbesitzer er wollte dann auch
nichts für den versand haben also noch mal großen dank dafür das ist echt cool dass man hier so eine
community hat dass man sich da auch gegenseitig manchmal hilft weil man manchmal solche kabel
auch einfach nicht rankommt ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht wonach ich suchen sollte es kann vielleicht
sein dass man das gehäuse vielleicht mal mit ganz vielen kratzern für fünf oder zehn euro findet
wo die kabel dann noch in takt sind oder irgendwelche kühlerhalter oder sowas ist ja auch schon mal
man könnte auch einfach das gehäuse nehmen was man schon hatte apropos kühlerhalter ich bin
erfreut dass hier alle schrauben dabei gewesen sind das ding wird da vernünftig irgendjemand
sie meinen ganz ehrlich kaum einer kauft jetzt seinen ersten pc gebraucht bei ebay und die
meisten leute haben noch ein gehäuse drauf kommen können hier habe ich natürlich auch die folie
abgezogen damit sich die hitze optimal übertragen kann und das gehäuse wird dieses hier sein das
ist ein aerocool die sind gut ich habe die sind die sind ganz gut habe ich jetzt schon ein paar
mal gehört dass die aerocool gehäuse ganz gut sind ihr wisst ja ich bin frecktele design oder
frecktele wie heißt der hersteller frecktele design genau fanboy ich habe die letzten vier
rechner generationen schon quasi er er quasi er so nach dem motto er 3r 4 5r 6r 7 so nach dem
motto gehabt und werde ich jetzt mit ihr für den nächsten auch holen
die haben netzteile wirklich sich gar nicht dass die netzteile haben die haben echt power supply
ist cool es sich gar nicht habe ich immer nur gehäuse bei denen geholt ich habe immer kombination
schon seit jahren kombination be quiet oder sie sonic netzteil mit frecktele design gehäuse
zu der großen version davon schon mal ein case review gemacht und das einfach das gleiche in
schwarz und ein wenig kleiner hier passt nämlich nur micro atx mainboards hinein
wir haben hier vorne auch wieder diesen argb streifen da kann man dann hier auf der oberseite
muss man glaube ich extra zuweisen den farbverlauf hiervon ändern zusätzlich mittlerweile hat
wirklich auch die billigsten sachen rgb dran noch eine leitleiste vom action einbauen den
blauen lüfter einmal umbauen so dass die warme luft rauskommt und keine kalte luft von da rein
muss hier vorne sieht man noch nicht ja wird man alles später sehen was glatte oder geriffelte
chips chips was meinst du für chips du meinst wahrscheinlich irgendwelche poka chips oder was
oder was was für chips zum essen pepega pepo fett chips lasst mal überlegen also ich
habe glaube ich schon ein jahr keine chips gefuttert weil ich bin schon dick genug ich
muss ja auch noch chips füttern aber tortilla chips mit mit dip beste also ordentlich scharf
schaffe tortilla chips mit dip excellent oh warte mal die katz chico was los moment
so die katz steht gerade auf der treppe und macht mau mau mau ja da guckst du komm her
chico hat kein bock hat kein bock
chico komm her
ich spule mal kurz vor was ist das hier für eine riesen usb stick gebannt mochte der das
ding nicht wenn er davon buten sollte es entweder nix was alter was ist mit dem rgb guck
mal aber irgendwie mochte der was ist mit dem rgb dann kriegst du ja belebte anfälle
von passiert also schwarzer bildschirm oder das ding ist ausgegangen und jetzt habe ich
den stick genommen und jetzt gibt es dafür ein modus zumindest zeigte das ding an also ganz
ganz komisch hängst du immer daneben also ist ja wirklich cool dass das hier so ein magnet zeug
ist aber wenn man das ding bewegt jetzt nicht aber vorführeffekt dann müsste das festkleben
leider kann sie oben kein lüfter drauf installieren sonst hätte ich das vielleicht gemacht aber
laut dem watsch pc bild hat er den lüfter viel zu früh eingebaut das muss man als letztes
einbauen wenn das alles andere alles andere so voll ist dass man schon gar nicht mehr
dran kommt kriegt der lüfter wahrscheinlich nicht mehr genug luft und das glaube ich das schlauste
was man machen kann gehäuse lüfter werde ich dann hier vorne noch drin installieren ob ein
oder zwei weiß ich nicht ich habe ja eigentlich genug liegt immer mehr lüfter rein also mehr
lüfter rein und also immer überdruck im gehäuse beste wie viele anschlüsse wir auf mainboard
haben da oben ist noch einer frei und hier unten 11 monat dankeschön big brain subscription ein
monat vor hypersubscriber dass es hier gar nicht möglich ist eine dreieinhalb zoll festplatte
einzubauen dachte ich weil es nämlich zumindest laut google bilder da sehen wir hier unten dass
dort eigentlich eine vorrichtung sein sollte für zwei dreieinhalb zoll für diese weg und diese
fehlt hier anzeige raus direkt paypal selbst wenn ich diese vorrichtung hätte case aufmachen
dafür dass ich hier das platten einbauen wieso ist überdruck besser dass kein staub ins gehäuse
reinkommt also das geht auch ohne schienen da kann man sich irgendwie unterdruck hast dann zieht
ja quasi staub von außen durch die ritzen ins gehäuse was basteln das ist nicht das problem aber ich
habe eben dieses teil hier an der stelle nicht LED leiste habe ich jetzt auch hier oben verbaut das
ist eine ganz wichtig also die fünf fps mehr durch die led durch die rgb leiste die sollte man sich
nicht nehmen lassen beim action glaube ich 2 euro 59 oder so jetzt durch oder vielleicht 2 euro 57
oder so weiß ich nicht und da haben wir hier eine das video aber nicht gekonnt an der lichtleiste
selber dran um den effekt einzustellen ich habe das jetzt einfach mal auf diesen farbwechsel modus
gelassen und ich finde das sieht wohl in ordnung aus ich habe zusätzlich hier oben noch ein stück
isolierband dran gepackt weil durch solche stellen wenn da licht durch scheint dann sieht das irgendwie
ein bisschen doof weil mir nach gehäuse bei den könnt ihr euch noch an diese richtig allen gehäuse
erinnern die man so 2005 rum hat irgendwie big tower so und ja solche solche fetten dinger und
das problem dabei war ich glaube den hatte ich mal wie übelst bekannt war ich glaube hier hatte ich
mal
alles klar zumindest das problem bei diesen dinger waren du hast dich total leicht geschnitten das
war das ist so ein typisches alles gehäuse was man so 2005 oder so rum hatte und das problem war
die dinger hier also die ganzen die die sachen die waren teilweise richtig scharfkantig du hast
dich auch gerne mal hier an den clips dinger geschnitten und so was also da da haben wir
echt schon letzten jahren fortschritte gemacht so in den letzten 15 dass man nicht gescheite
gehäuse gibt da war schon viel müll dabei und zu der zeit war es auch so man hat sich big tower
gekauft um big tower zu haben nicht weil man es gebraucht hat ja deswegen ja und ansonsten
ja ja ja würde ich auch sagen niemand braucht diesen rgb streifen da vorne dran der geht
bitte stelle immer vor du hast es neben dir auf der erde stehen das ist doch nur nervig wenn du
permanent im augenwinkel so ein rgb streifen flimmern siehst
oma ich bin gleich wieder da
benchmark ist auch hier das ist glaube ich nicht so spannend das ding dürfte ganz gut sein also für
75 euro dürfte es auf jeden fall ganz gut sein nee habe ich nix geguckt
ok was kommt am ende raus erst mal ganz wichtig der minecraft benchmark minecraft
fps 64 kann man doch arbeiten mit oder bauen mit die fortnite
hier 125 fps kannst du gar kannst die ganze nex über competitive fortnite man werden gut das
läuft nicht richtig das ruckelt schon im video zu mal mehr sagen muss man hat warfare mit 82
fps ruckelt wie andere spiele mit 30 fps verfolgt einer von euch irgendwie fortnite e-sports also
ich nicht aber was ich mich frage ist es gab ja mal diese diese diese weltmeisterschaft wo irgendwie
dieser dieser dieser einen typ den vorher keiner kannte der da irgendwie eine million gewonnen hat
oder so und damals haben irgendwie alle gedacht oh cool jetzt jetzt geht es voll ab aber das ist
nie abgehoben oder fortnite e-sports das ist nie da ist nie nach diesem turnier jemals wieder was
gekommen oder ich habe keine ahnung mehr wie der typ hieß gab dieses war irgendwie 2017 oder so
fragen wenn ich war das war gab es diese fortnite weltmeisterschaft oder ich kann mich da ich habe
es nur am rande verfolgt weil fortnite ist überhaupt nicht mein game und alle voll gehypt
und mega geil und so und danach gab es nie wieder was
wow huge aim massive erst mal schön auf bobs zielen
hast du vor die beta von cold war zu spielen habe ich schon gemacht ein paar stunden
das spiel ist von von war nicht allen weg 2008 oder so das ist ein richtig geiles spiel wenn
man es nicht permanent action will ein bisschen was doch jeden triffen sich mal angeben will
wenn er den weg noch nicht gespielt hat ist wirklich top eigentlich ja wohl ganz ok aber
mit den fortnite werden bin ich nicht ganz zufrieden wie so 120 fps 120 fps ist ok bei
dem loka gaming pc so gewesen macht mag das ding auf einmal keine älteren cpus mehr oder
wie sieht das aus ich meine die 185 fps die können wir nicht von irgendwo her also im
durchschnitt und dann 0,1 low fps oder so hat man sogar in dem aufnahmeschnipsel gesehen dass es
da einen kleinen hakler gab aber diese haker waren kurioserweise immer in den besten momenten wenn
man gerade wenn gerade einfach nichts passiert ist und man irgendwas gesucht hat oder so wenn
ich damit jemanden gebaut oder so ok aber an sich also 0,75 euro kannst du wirklich nicht sagen das
wirklich sehr ordentlich das ist wirklich wirklich echt echt ok so was gucken wir was gucken wir uns
jetzt an max du bist ja ziemlich erfahren kommt drauf an den was naja ich lese weiter hast du
tips für ein bewerbungsgespräch im software development bereich
was willst du wissen eher nicht wie gesagt ich war bei zwei unterschiedlichen arbeitgebern bisher
wenn man mal mein vorheriges leben und versuchte ausbildung außen vor lässt
es kommt dann auf den laden an
ja geht geht wenn du ein github account hast es ist auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt also was ich
zumindest bei meinem bewerbungsgespräch noch im kopf habe was ich aus meiner sicht
wo sehen sie sich in zehn jahren genau was aus meiner sicht was gebracht hat aber das kann ich
halt auch jetzt nicht sagen ok das bringt immer was weil ich wie gesagt ich muss mir nicht so
oft bewerben was was gebracht hat war dass man von sich aus was gesagt hat also sprich ich musste
dann damals diesen komischen test machen nach dem motto was kann man alles und so danach gab
es also ganz normales bewerbungsgespräch und ich habe halt damals gesagt ok als ich halt reingekommen
bin in das büro wo das bewerbungsgespräch sprich war habe ich halt irgendwas zu diesem test gesagt
habe ich gesagt hier das mit dem cisco switch das war ganz schön schwierig und da hat man
halt instant ein gesprächsthema gehabt da haben die natürlich gefragt ja warum ich
dachte ja ich wusste genau wie das heißt am liebsten nicht mein gefallen blabla blabla was
auch immer weil ansonsten sitzen beide seiten voreinander und überlegen sich was können wir
den anderen jetzt fragen also manchmal ist es denke ich gar nicht verkehrt also wenn es passt je
nachdem was es für ein laden ist wenn man von sich aus was sagt jetzt ohne die anderen komplett
vollzuschwätzen weil dann kannst du zumindest ein bisschen einfluss drauf was jetzt gesprächsthema
ist und nicht random zeug wo du auch nicht mit rechnest ja guck mal das ist doch super ja das da
sieht man aber dass das was bringt klassische frage also was ich wissen sollte kommt wie gesagt
kommt ein bisschen auf den laden an ich bin jetzt auch nicht so der wahnsinns pro drinne aber das
hier finde ich schon mal gut und daran sieht man dass manche das nicht alle aber das viele
unternehmen da auch ein bisschen mit der mit der zeit gehen und zwar er schreibt ich habe
ein githab repo mit dem minecraft mit geschnitten meinten dass das ja auch sehr kräftig war und
dass sie mich deswegen eingeladen haben also manche unternehmen sind da schon mit der mit
der zeit gegangen und ich weiß du hast ja wirklich viel arbeit reingesteckt das sieht jetzt ja auch
vorzeigbar aus ja ich habe ja schon ein paar screenshots auf dem discord von gesehen ja was
so die klassischen fragen sind es kommt es kommt echt auf den auf den laden an ich mein wenn du
wenn du nach den den standard stonks dingern gehst dann fragen die dich nach irgendwelchen
software algorithmen geschützt suchst du was für als ausbildung oder als arbeit
eigentlich die auf die frage ausbildungsplatz oder hast du schon
werksstudent ok
das kommt ganz drauf an ob das leute machen die personal abteilung sind und von der technik keine
ahnung haben oder ob das leute sind die sich halt wirklich dafür interessieren also wenn das die
die personal abteilungsleute sind oder irgendwelche stonks abteilungs typen oder so dann kann das
durchaus sein dass so doofes zeug gefragt wird also ein paar dieser blöden fragen werden auf jeden
fall dran kommen oder so sagen sie wenn sie eine sache an sich ändern könnten was wäre
das irgendwie so komische dinger das es gibt ja ich habe das gefühl es gibt da mittlerweile
so ganze how to dumme fragen stellen im vorstellungsgespräch für irgendwelche
personalen menschen ok dann wirst du da wirst du mit einigen stonks fragen rechnen müssen
ja deswegen ist es vielleicht gar nicht schlecht wenn du die chance hast dass du am anfang
irgendwas sagst wurde dass du so ein bisschen beeinflussen kannst in welche richtung richtung
die ganzen sachen geht ansonsten kommt natürlich auch drauf an was die firma macht also was was
gerade bei den amis voll angesagt ist ich habe keine ahnung wie das hier ist da denkt ja jeder
laden er wäre das nächste google facebook netflix amazon oder sonst was und stellen dementsprechend
auch beknackte fragen so nach dem motto irgendwelche algorithmen dinger so implementieren sie ein
selbst sortierende liste mit bla bla bla wie würden sie das anstellen und solche sachen keine
ahnung wie das hier in deutschland ist bei den amis ist das gerade voll angesagt dass
die an dass sie sich alles in die google fragen abgucken invertieren sie ein benea genau solche
beknackten fragen genau so was meine ich ja aber ob man das gleich am anfang fragt glaube ich
nicht als werksstudent glaube ich auch nicht dass sowas dass sowas dran kommt ja also ich
kann den allein jetzt keine super tollen tipps geben so was schauen wir uns mal als nächstes
an erst mal schauen ob ich nicht noch irgendwelche questions übersehen habe
das habe ich habe ich habe schon gespielt so was gucken wir uns als nächstes an
anrunde sagt wüsste nicht mal was ein binärbaum ist da kann ich nicht in nichts invertieren ja
das stimmt ich habe ehrlich gesagt aus dem kopf auch kein ich glaube das sind das sind welche die
mit nur zwei plättern oder zwei lief notes also quasi du hast du hast den knoten punkt
und bei einem binary tree kannst du maximal zwei child notes haben und die wieder nur zwei
child notes deswegen binary und die wieder nur zwei child notes wieso hier wupplose nicht max
fps das liegt daran weil ich den account erstellt habe ohne dass ich vorhabe zu streamen und irgendwann
habe ich mir gedacht alter fang doch mal ein bisschen an zu streamen oder hieß ich schon
wupplose und habe mich nicht umbenannt weil ich mir überlegt habe ok eigentlich ist die idee gar
nicht so schlecht weil dann finden den weg von youtube wirklich nur die big brain gescheiten
leute was man ja auch sieht es gibt kaum einen channel und jetzt mal hier chat ernsthaft es
gibt kaum einen channel auf twitch der so einen big brain und gesittene gesittene cute chat hat
wie ich ist echt so bester chat hier nur die elite hier genau man kann sich mittlerweile
auf twitch glaube unbenennt ja wie hieß die marke des thermostats die ich gekauft habe also du
musst unterscheiden zwischen dem china hersteller und den reseller also ein reseller ist zum
beispiel also ich zeigte jetzt mal wie diese dinge aussehen diese teile hier viel zu teuer
übrigens viel zu teuer kostet bei aliexpress 25 dollar diese dinger sind das hier du siehst
es gibt von vielen vielen herstellern und aktuell gibt es die habe ich letztens gesehen wenn man die
kaufen will von also wie gesagt das ist alles der gleiche china hersteller aber unterschiedliche
genau hier kriegst du zum beispiel drei stück für 100 euro was ein bisschen besser ist da sind es
nur 33 von aliexpress ist natürlich immer noch am günstigsten aber du siehst es in alles die
gleiche sind sie eigentlich von revolt bei dem anderen sind sie von sonst was aber das sind
alles die gleichen alles das gleiche gerät runter letztendlich was die machen ist ihren
eigenen aufkleber draufdrucken gut ist guckst du noch deutsche streamer ich guck ab und zu mal
speedruns mit deutschem commentary und ich guck ab und zu mal beim lost mal immer mal wieder rein
aber nicht lang aber so wirklich regelmäßig lange deutsche streamer gucken mache ich nicht hast du
ein ding zu dem thermostat wo es günstig ist also wenn du nee leider nicht die gibt zwar über
aliexpress also da würde ich da ich würde es mir normalerweise über aliexpress kaufen für 21
dollar das problem ist dass die irgendwie ihre versand sachen verkackt haben bei aliexpress weil
es kostet 41 euro versand das natürlich bescheuert nach afghanistan liefern ist noch teurer wie
sieht es nach china aus also noch teurer das ist ein bisschen doof dann lohnt sich das ja überhaupt
nicht mehr da muss ja schon wird sie da muss ja schon 100 stück bestellen dass ich das lohnt so
nach dem oder wir sollten mal andere versand anbieten weil dann würde ich mir direkt bei
aliexpress kaufen also ich mein 30 euro ist ok also das könnte man das was man hier bei wurde
gelöscht also das was man hier gerade bei google gesehen hat muss drei stück für 99 euro gab das
ist ok das kann man sich noch kaufen hier den dreier pack kostet 33 pro thermostat das ist ok
aber wie gesagt ich so ich warte drauf bis es also ich müsste mir jetzt ja eigentlich noch
mal so so zehn stück kaufen dass ich meine heizung damit ausstatten kann und ich warte erst mal bis
ich das ein bisschen länger ausprobiert habe weil ich kann es noch nicht wirklich ruhigen
gewissens empfehlen ich habe das jetzt erst ein paar tage laufen und ich will erst mal gucken dass
es bei aliexpress und irgendwo anders ein bisschen günstiger ist also sollte ich das irgendwo mal
finden so für 20 euro und dann jetzt nicht gerade 40 euro versandt dann würde ich da sofort
zuschlagen und 10er pack kaufen mitbekommen dass knossi gesquattet wurde echt man kann in deutschland
gesquattet werden das höchste der gefühle was ich mitbekommen habe ist in deutschland dass
leute mal feuerwehr heimgeschickt bekommen haben und so was das die kind of mana da kam alles
feuerwehrpolizei das komplette dorf echt wir haben das geschafft wir haben das hingekriegt
das komplette dorf da anrückt wie genau funktionieren die dinger das mache ich in einem der nächsten
streams das ist das sind sich die thermostate du brauchst quasi nur einen hub oder beziehungsweise
halt einen stick und ein endgerät wurde das einrichtet und dann kannst du die quasi perlen
so ein bisschen wie mit wlan oder bluetooth oder seawave kannst du perlen und dann kannst du über
eine oberfläche die ganzen thermostate steuern oder eben automatisch aktuell habe ich nur im
wohnzimmer und macht so dass es automatisch um 19 uhr angeht und um 22 wieder aus dass die
polizei hat identifiziert ok was jemand hat gemeldet das gas austritt bei ihm aber warum
muss da dass die polizei im sport ist ja nicht sport sport ist ja es ist amie polizeienhaut
warum so was muss die polizei mit ihrer speziale andere anrücken mit gas austritt ok und wer da
echt mit seinem handy anruft ist dumm der schlaue 37 jahre oder ich war es nicht leute ich bin auch
nicht 37 zum glück nur 36 ich kann es nicht gewesen sein aber wenn mit seinem handy jemand
anruft und squattet der ist wirklich absolut low brain also am besten ist man man squattet die
leute gar nicht aber dann noch mit dem handy das anzurufen ist wirklich bescheuert
der war 36 ja ich bin zwar 36 aber ich war es nicht chatte gerade mit aliexpress wie
soll ob die andere versandt hat chillfreak wenn die das machen weiß dann bestelle ich gleich mit
ich habe kein setke soll ich hinzufügen brauche das hau mal setke brauche setke
ok moment leute ich füge setke kurz mal hinzu
setke hinzugefügt aber das dauert ein bisschen bis ffz das hinzufügt außerdem muss man muss
man chat re-loaden und das dauert ein paar minuten bis das drin ist
ja das habe ich auch also der button geht nicht schwer aber ich muss halt ordentlich
auf den button drauf hauen dass er überhaupt angeht das display
ja also ich habe ich habe mitgekriegt was manche streamer richtig big brain sind und
quasi zu unterschiedlichen anlässen unterschiedliche emotes haben also bei
dense gaming finde ich das ganz extrem der macht wenn er seinen halloween oder
horror monat macht dann tauscht er alle seine emotes aus ich meine ich kriege es noch nicht
mal hin überhaupt emotes zu machen und er tauscht einfach alle seine emotes aus
ok da musst du das auch ja ich steuere es auch nur über home assistant
excellent musik so was können wir uns jetzt noch mal geben schaut ihr mal ein video zu
knossi an
das ding wird ja auch total zweck entfremdet wieder das ist ja eigentlich so ein so ein
ai bastel board von nvidia und die leute es gehen jetzt her und bauen
irgendwelche emulator rechner draus eigentlich eigentlich ziemlich big brain von nvidia weil
die können das natürlich nicht als emulator plattform vermarkten da kommt dann gleich
sony microsoft nintendo und alle regen sich drüber auf wenn man was ans emulator plattform
vermarktet erinnert ihr euch noch an die solja boy konsole die hatte auch als emulator plattform
vermarktet dann war vorbei gut der hat die spiele vor installiert das war ja noch ein
anderes problem falls ich nur einer dran erinnert aber viele bauen jetzt sich da so eine emulator
plattform draus und das soll es wohl ziemlich gut sein
lieg lieg excel auf dem raspberry pi schon gesehen ja habe ich mir glaube ich sogar schon in meine
jahre mich nicht mal was war das wollte ich nämlich mal ausprobieren habe ich gelesen
ist ja schon vor einem vor einem monat oder so gab es das ja so was haben wir hier sonst
noch für die sachen 10g network upgrade er kondition server
das ist langweilig das gucken wir nicht legos alter der dude kreativ ist das müsste am lassen
ne aber es x e wird nicht wirklich auf dem pil auf dora
echt wirklich
jetzt
echt jetzt
oh das müssen wir ausprobieren das muss das probieren aus exzellent
das ist jetzt sicher auf maler musik
primedale gucken aber nicht gemacht das ist cool das probieren wir aus
ich habe jetzt auch sich wieder heim ja für ein thermostat und ein feuten luftfeuer für
ein luftfeuchtigkeit und temperatur sensor zum ausprobieren gerade nur zum ausprobieren
wenn das gut läuft baue ich baue ich noch ein bisschen mehr sich bietz euch ein ok was
muss man machen register account und dann download wie es für hyperweiser vor allem
ja nice dass das probieren wir aus im stream leute
ja ja ich logg mich da noch ein wir machen den fake account
der desktop ist beste will irgendjemand hat irgendjemand was wirklich gegen diesen desktop
kann ich gar nicht verstehen nur der beste content auf dem desktop
eine mischung aus twitch emotes und katzenbilder also da kann man doch eigentlich nix dagegen
haben das ist poggers der desktop
übrigens mein meme board hat einen bug der spielt dieses eine gif und nur dieses eine
gif viel zu schnell abguck alle anderen gifs vollkommen ok von der geschwindigkeit aber
das klo gif ist kaputt wie hatten wir es denn jetzt hier warum wird man manchmal der
hintergrund schwarz microsoft logik das probieren wir im nächsten stream aus da bin ich sehr
gespannt drauf es x auf dem raspberry pi da bin ich wirklich enorm gespannt darauf
wie das funktioniert huge gespannt drauf
ok das kommt uns jetzt noch an also was wird hier geupgraded rgb ok erstmal auf 4k stellen
obwohl wir nur in 1080p streamen
warum und was ist das hier ist das ein netzwerk festplatte was macht der da wo ist der sinn
sieht aus wie ein kratzbaum overwatch underrated nee overwatch ist nicht underrated overwatch
ist einfach noch kacke mittlerweile
ja
ach das ist der hintergrund den er für seine videos hat das hat mit dem video gar nichts
zu tun alles klar also für 4 500 dollar kriegt man einen ziemlich guten 10 gigabit switch
wenn man wirklich 4 500 dollar ausgibt entweder die mittelklasse mikrotik dinger oder oder
den da der ist auch gut wenn man so viel geld ausgeben will da kriegt man nämlich 12 ports
also für plus und vier ports komfort 10g mal gucken was er für ein hat wir spulen
mal ein bisschen vor was ist das denn
das ist irgend so ein ding womit man normalerweise kartoffelpuffer dreht oder sowas in der küche
gute taktik warum nicht geht immerhin könnte eine schere oder besser verwenden aber wozu
wozu sollte man sowas machen wobei dass es bestimmt kokona lernt der das eigentlich
auch aufschießen können ich würde nicht wundern wenn leute in
den usa ihre pakete aufschießen
was geht mit der musik ab
das hat doch ein messer
was ist das für eine logik
jetzt muss ich nicht verstehen das muss ich nicht verstehen er nimmt erst mal irgend so
komischen essenswände um die box auf zu machen und dann in der box nimmt ein messer
excellent
ok wir spulen mal ein bisschen vor bis er den netgear switch
ok wir überspringen das ganze mal gucken ok er ist der switch also
halt mal still ich muss mal kurz gucken ok ok
so also 4 sfp plus ports vermute ich mal ich erkenne es nicht so ganz
ich würde jetzt mal vermuten das sind vier mal sfp plus 10g und das sind wahrscheinlich
1g ports weil es wäre ganz schön viele 10g kupfer ports wenn das wirklich 10g kupfer
ports wären also das sind ja 24 ne wie viele werden aber wie viel sind das 2 4 8 16 24
kupfer ports wenn die 10g wären das wäre ganz schön teurer switch
gucken wir mal hat das ganze verlinkt switch amazon reflink excellent
pass mal auf wir debaten den reflink jetzt
tommy du musst refreshen dann geht das ich habe es hinzugefügt das kann ok hat er nicht
was gesagt von 4 500 euro
das ist ein bisschen teuer es kann aber auch sein dass die amazon preise grad zacken
ich sag doch das ist teurer wenn das alles 10g ports sind deswegen hat mich gewundert
dass der was von 4 500 euro erzählt oder 4 500 dollar weil 24 10g ports sind teuer die
sage ist ist das überhaupt 10g hier 24 10g ports ja was gebraucht für ich gucke jetzt
mal auf ebay ok das ist was das kann man sich auch auf
jeden fall gebraucht kaufen also das kann man also würde ich das würde ich auch auf
jeden fall also wenn ich die chance hätte gebraucht kaufen
aber 700 ist immer noch ist echt echt eine hausnummer die sache ist die was haben die
so für power consumption power consumption was brauchen die so
power consumption power
87 watt ist ordentlich
ach so das ist voller auslastung ok idol ist ja viel wichtiger idol was hat das ding idol
mit irgendwie 5 6 ports für eine auslastung
kann das hier raus idol let us check also hier
ja und was kam jetzt raus
let us check idol und dann schreibt ihr keine idol hin oder was
das ist ja bescheuert
ja aber 87 watt ist nicht idol das ist 87 watt ist volle pulle
zumindest eindeutig zu viel als dass ich mir einfach irgendwo hinstellen würde wie da
stand es direkt ganz oben
ganz oben
das habe ich doch auf da steht nirgendwo da steht dass die es checken mit idol und 12
connects so aber das hier ist ja nur der wert für 12 connects
das ist nicht der wert für idol
87 watt idol mit 12 angeschlossene clients wäre
ist im bereich des möglichen aber wäre trotzdem ganz schön viel
und die schreiben ja auch hier sie können das nicht genug stressen und es geht nie über
87 watt also das ist nicht der idol verbrauch
was hilft mir ein router wenn ich nichts anschließe
er kann ja auch nichts routen wenn du nichts angeschlossen hast
ja gut was auch immer er braucht er braucht aber recht ordentlich auf jeden fall also
ich kann euch sagen meiner mein hier den da
der braucht ungefähr 20 watt idol mit
allen vier ports kupfer belegt und ich glaube drei ports class belegt
natürlich brauchst du idol consumption du brauchst du musst wissen was das ding braucht
weil 90 prozent ist das 95 prozent ist das ja idol
das ist eigentlich das wo es die größte zeit verbringt
ob das mal unter extrem lastbedingungen 87 watt verbraucht ist das eine aber ob das
sagen wir 60 watt verbraucht einfach nur idol und mit angeschlossene clients das ist ja
was anders also meiner braucht ungefähr 20 bisschen
über 20 watt was hast du an die sfp plus an die sfp
plus ports angeschlossen direkt attach kabel und mit den unify modulen
und ich hab noch stimmt so gar nicht sind vier belegt und ich hab noch ein mikrotik
sfp plus auf 45 modul dran was auch funktioniert
75 watt für den switch also das heißt das switch braucht allein wenn er an ist 75 watt
das ist ganz schön viel das das zieht das zieht gut stromrechnung
ja gut deswegen kostet auch so viel gut keine ahnung was die strompreise in usa sind
wie auch nur ein netzteil
bei einem 1700 euro switch nur ein netzteil
es kann natürlich sein dass der intern trotzdem zwei netzteile hat
da bist ja fast mit dem cisco switch billiger
wobei ist netgehe nicht cisco mittlerweile
gibt das wenn es fertig die die die für fürs reinschrauben die dinger
schaumdinger anschrauben
warum haben so viele leute dieses da tech rack
schildfreak vielleicht antwortet er noch
also wie gesagt wenn du den verkäufer beim aliexpress shop irgendwie dazu überredet
bekommst
einen anderen versand zu machen als 47 euro nach deutschland dann bestelle ich mit zehn
stück
das ist das die es haben total viel dieses data nicht das ist gar nicht so billig
ich habe mir das ich habe mir das auch mal angeguckt
da die wollen irgendwie 250 euro für so ein kleines rack
was im vergleich zu profi racks nicht viel ist aber für so ein heimbereich schon so
eine sache
bei wo bloß als name weil ich ich muss ich jeden strengler fünf war erklärt ich habe
mir den account gemacht bevor ich jemals angefangen bevor ich vor hatte zu streamen
und dann habe ich mir irgendwann überlegt okay fängst du auch an zu streamen da hieß
ich halt wo bloß und hat mir gedacht okay eigentlich ist es gar nicht so schlecht weil
dann kommen nur die guten leute von youtube rüber und finden
das ja auch funktioniert weil du hast ja auch gefunden
also dass es funktioniert guck mal das ist viel zu teuer so ein komisches bissl metal
350 euro what the fuck das ist mega teuer dieser kram
350 euro für so ein kleines kackrack zwar zwar ein 12h u rack 350 euro
das ist übelst teuer es mag zwar im vergleich zu den zu großen fetten racks
ist nichts aber das ist für so privat super teuer
das ist server metal also ganz ehrlich wenn man es wirklich wenn man es wirklich günstig
haben will wirklich günstig nimmt man sich einfach
einen ikea rack nein nein dann nimmt man sich so was hier
lack rack das ist dann zwar nicht sonderlich professionell
aber es kostet nicht viel lack rack
hier lack wandregal ich meine es ist nicht schön
ne ne ne nicht wandregal tisch tischbrommer ikea lack
hier den da so guck mal du hast die auswahl zu es ist ein bisschen hässlich aber es kostet
10 euro zu es kostet 350 euro und ist ein richtiger rack
und die pressspannfüße halten so fest ich gehe mal davon aus du wirst da keine irgendwie
40 kilo usv rein hängen können so ohne weiteres aber man kann ja schienen machen von hinten
nach vorne und das dürfte auch genug halten denke ich mal mal gucken wie sie das hier
gebaut haben also für irgendwelche switches würde ich sagen haltet auf jeden fall
eine 4he kiste an nur zwei schrauben weiß ich nicht ja ob ich das machen würde
ja man könnte das sicherlich noch ein bisschen upgraden man könnte hier bestimmt noch irgendwelche
muttern reinsetzen oder so vorne muss man sich mal überlegen wie man das ob man das
irgendwie hinbekommt aber zumindest ist es preislich besser ich habe mir damals einen
rack gekauft von denen hier aber auch nur weil es im angebot war das war nämlich auch
die normalen sachen viel viel zu teuer so ein kleines ding habe ich mir damals gekauft
12 hu ja ich habe es in black 12 oder 15 hu ich bin mir da gar nicht mal sicher ob 12
hu das kleinste so und da war es aber ein bisschen billiger und ich habe das damals
für irgendwie 100 120 euro oder so gekauft das ist dass das geht noch aber es ist eigentlich
auch viel zu teuer also ich glaube wüsste ich mir noch mal irgendwo normales rack hinstellen
ich würde mir wahrscheinlich auch mal so testweise so ein rack bauen das probiere ich mal aus
billiges kia rack das hier soll auch gut sein nein ist nicht gut den habe ich mir bestellt
ich weiß nicht ob ich mir den bestellt habe ist das der netzwerkschrank der hatte nämlich
nicht genug tiefe wenn es nur der netzwerkschrank ist tiefe tiefe tiefe 160 euro ja doch das
ist normaler da hast du das problem dass deine rückwand hat und die meisten server sind ein
ticken länger und die passen da nicht rein und was auch das problem ist die tür die
dann je nach konstellation nicht mehr richtig zugehen und ich habe mir das auch bestellt
mal ursprünglich und es hat ups geliefert mit kaputter mit kaputter tür
chillfreak die antwort von aliexpress das ist so eine typische china antwort das ist
komplett einfach nur ausgedacht als könnte als dürfte nur fedex elektronik verschippern
die einen motor enthält ganz bestimmt das ist die bescheuertste erbegründung die ich
seit langem gehört habe ich kann verstehen warum die das machen wollen die wollen halt
sichergehen dass der kram auch unbeschadet ankommt und wahrscheinlich wollen sie die
leute dadurch dazu verleiten eben nicht nur fünf zu bestellen sondern gleich 50
tool das wurde von automatisch antwort hat ja das wollten wir auch machen ok wir kommen
jetzt schnell noch das eine video hier vom was er hier noch eingebaut hat mit seinem
10g netzwerk und mit seinem startech rack weil die sache ist halt die wenn es wirklich
45 dollar kostet pro pro gerät und bei aliexpress ist das thermostat 10 bis 15 euro billiger
also du musst eigentlich mindestens mal einen 10er pack bestellen dass sich das anfängt
zu rechnen gar nicht ganz fünfer pack bestellen und erst dann fängt sich an zu rechnen weiß
nicht ob das lohnt sich irgendwie nicht der ist smart das ist ein switch der switch nicht
nur einfach der ist auch noch big brain switch der ich bin ja auch ja genau chillfreaks kann
durchaus sein dass die wenn die das ganz offiziell und ordentlich beschriftet mit fedex
machen dass du dann auch noch zoll bezahlen musst ja very smart
ja ja macht er das haben switcher so an sich dass die switchen ja wofür braucht man so
ein switch zu hause gar nicht also mir fällt kein anwendungszweck ein wo man zu hause aktuell
28 ports 10g braucht mein switch ist schon extrem überdimensioniert wie gesagt ich
verwende davon gerade mal die hälfte der ports und darüber mache ich auch bei ansatzweise
nicht 10 gigabit also ich verwende vier ports davon vier ports davon das ist ungefähr
die hälfte der ports die ne noch nicht mal ganz drittel ja doch die hälfte nicht wirklich
also ein drittel der ports verwende ich
hälfte klingt besser das braucht man nicht
das gibt also wenn man sich den 10g switch kauft was sinnvoll ist ist wenn man sagt man
mal ein fileserver hat oder so mit ssd und oder viel magnet festplatten und zfs oder
so was also sprich wenn man einen fileserver hat der ordentlich iow performance hat und
man hat beispielsweise einen rechner wo man video editing macht und so was drauf dass
man dann beiden 10g karte spendiert und sich einen günstigen 10g switch kauft das sind
10 günstige 10g switches von mikrotik kriegst du zum beispiel mit 2 bis 4 10g ports und
dann alternativ mit 2 bis 14g ports plus irgendwie sagen wir mal noch noch 24 bis zu 24 1g ports
das ist preisleistungstechnisch ganz gut kostet dann irgendwann so um 200 300 euro das ist
in ordnung oder oder richtig günstig von mikrotik die mit 4g ports mit 4 mal 10g ports für
glaube ich sogar nur 120 euro das ist ok
das ist das ist top
ja du hast übrigens recht es ist genau die hälfte von den ports diesen switch hier braucht
man absolut gar nicht also mir fällt im heimbereich nichts ein was man damit machen soll
genau und ganz praktisch wäre wenn man die 10g ports auch als 2,5 und 5g ports verwenden
kann weil sich im heimbereich ganz ganz langsam also wirklich sehr gemächlich im heimbereich
2,5g und 5g ports langsam etablieren warum auch immer die nicht einfach gesagt haben
scheiß drauf wir machen gleich 10g weiß ich nicht wahrscheinlich wegen den kupferkabeln
die die meisten im einsatz haben aber so langsam ganz gemächlich setzt sich 2,5 und 5g auch
im heimbereich durch und die meisten switches mit 10g ports können auch 2,5 und 5g machen
und die ports sind wahrscheinlich billiger welche switches kannst du empfehlen von hp
keine ahnung kenne ich mich nicht mit aus also ich empfehle immer im heimbereich gerade im
heimbereich mikrotik switche weil die feature mäßig und preisleistungs mäßig einfach
die besten sind ab und die ein oder anderen unify ubiquity sachen sind auch ganz gut unify
switches habe ich bisher ein bogendrum gemacht aber wenn es wirklich preisleistungs mäßig
gut sein soll dann mikrotik
natürlich funktioniert das das ist alles standardmäßig vlan 1 ohne config switch da
einfach der switch
aber wenn du wirklich einen hp switch haben willst habe ich keine ahnung
also wenn du den switch für dein bureau suchst guck dir das mal an nehm dir den hier wenn
du nicht viele wenn du nicht viele 10g ports brauchst dann nehm den css3 nehm den hier
das ist das beste was du für das geld kriegst du kriegst 24 1g ports und 2 10g ports was
besseres kannst du nicht bekommen für 130 euro
switch technisch wie laut sind die dinger geht geht also nicht nicht sonderlich laut
die mikrotik dinger manche sind sogar komplett passiv
weiß ich nicht ob der komplett passiv ist aber sie sind auf jeden fall nicht laut wieso
hat er klaut im namen weil mikrotik cool sein will da ist nichts klaut an den dinger
das heißt nichts es kann durchaus sein dass da standardmäßig passiv geliefert wird
können wir mal gucken
die haben immer ganz gute tests für sowas ja
lack of fan noise der ist passiv
der ist passiv
gekühlt
guck mal also das ist mal wirklich für den heimbereich der optimale switch wenn man sowas
haben will du kriegst 10 du kriegst 2 10g ports du kriegst 24 gigabit ports das ding
hat nur 11 watt idle power und hat noch nicht mal einen lüfter der krach macht also das
ist wirklich der beste switch und er kostet nur 130 euro also einen besseren switch kannst
du dir wenn es reicht was der kann kannst du dir nicht holen falls du ein bisschen mehr
features brauchst holst du dir nicht den css 326 sondern holst dir den crs kannst du
die auch holen der hat ein bisschen firmen wir ein bisschen mehr funktion allerdings
ist die sache halt die diese neuen funktionen naja also du kannst mit der cpu hier drinnen
nicht viele sachen machen also wenn du hast hier zwar die ganzen routing und firewall
funktionen drinnen beim crs aber die cpu ist nicht dafür gedacht es gibt auch ein
4x10g ja es gibt keine ahnung was das jetzt für einer ist ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine
ahnung was der unterschied zwischen dem und dem hier ist hat irgendjemand eine ahnung
das ist rm und das ist en ich habe keine ahnung was der unterschied dazwischen ist 24
sfp plus cage das 24 rackmount nee rackmount ah der ist nicht rackmount oder ah der ist
en und der ist rackmount ah verstehe aber wenn du einfach nur zehn wenn du einfach
nur ports brauchst nimm den hier wenn du einfach nur 14g ports brauchst nimm den hier da habe
ich übrigens noch ein hier den wollte ich mal verlosen habe ich aber noch nie auf die
reihe gekriegt da nimmste den hier kostet auch nicht viel kostet 115 euro 115 euro
und du kriegst vier 10g ports und einen einen 1 gigabit port über diesen port kannst du
den switch sogar poe betreiben du suchst einen switch mit 10g ports und mindestens 24 oh
das wird teuer also wenn du 24 10g ports mit poe haben willst falls du das so gemeint
hast das wird teuer wobei ich glaube können die nicht sogar poe können die nicht sogar
poe können kein poe ja also ich kann dir empfehlen guck dir mal die mikrotik dinger
durch die haben für so ziemlich jeden anwendungszweck irgendwas ja also also poe switch die brauchen
auch ordentlich ordentlich lüftung dann schnelles gewinnspiel jetzt ne ja warum können die
sfp ports nur 10g sfp ports sind für 1g sfp plus ports sind für 10g es gibt qspf oder
so ähnlich dieses dann bist du 40g 4 mal 10g da haben die auch einen guten switch was ist
ein poe port mit strom mit strom über über über das kabel also wenn du die haben hier
auch einen 10 4s plus dann brauchst du sowas hier dann brauchst du sowas hier dann kriegste
4 ports sfp plus und 24 ports dings und da musst halt noch schauen ob der poe kann ja
genau und der kann auch poe out dann ist wahrscheinlich das hier so ungefähr der switch den du haben
willst und sogar der ist nicht mal sonderlich teuer ich glaube das kostet irgendwas um
300 euro ja also du kannst dich bei mikrotik preisleistungsmäßig echt nicht beschweren
ich meine das ist echt enorm wenn du dir überlegst du kriegst für um die 300 euro
ich weiß es hört ich müsste echt mal mikrotik partner partnership machen oder so weil ich
die weil ich die immer so so so anpreise die sollten mir ein bisschen was können die fritz
boxen poe die sollten mir eigentlich mal ein bisschen was bezahlen aber muss schon mal
ehrlich sagen also preisleistungsmäßig kann da kein anderer hersteller mithalten du kriegst
für 300 euro einen switch 24 ports 2 obs moment ich bin beim falschen ja du kriegst
für du kriegst für um die 300 euro 24 ports gigabit 4 ports sfp plus 10 gigabit plus
poe also das ist wirklich echt top da kann da kann keiner mit also wenn man damit einverstanden
ist dass man eben halt keinen sysco switch oder kein sonst was oder kein hp oder sonst
wie nimmt man mikrotik nimmt also preisleistungsmäßig sind die wirklich absolute erste sahne was
heißt bei dem switch dual damit ist meistens gemeint du kannst einen firmware upgrade machen
kannst booten und wenn es nicht geht kannst du zurückswitchen auf die alte firmware und
direkt wieder starten es könnte aber auch sein dass die mein du kannst switch os und
ruta os laufen lassen müssen wir mal gucken ruta ruta os und switch os aber diese firma
switching geschichte haben die auf jeden fall auch du kannst dir du kannst ruta os oder
switch os drauf installieren der unterschied ist ruta os ist das normale was 30 milliarden
funktionen hatten relativ kompliziert ist und switch os kannst du eigentlich nicht
viel machen außer wie lands angeben und sonst was ist die config ist einfacher ich nehme
ruta os wenn es e wenn es unterstützt wird ja so aber sind wir stehen geblieben hier
hey max du bist hey max du bist ja gut informiert in sachen smart optimierung zeige mal hier
haufe bald ein haus und muss elektrik etc sowieso neu machen die frage würdest du hier
auf eine komplette lösung kein nix oder so setzen oder eins lösung ich kann dir da
ehrlich gesagt nicht großartig helfen das haus hier das ist ja nicht neu in dem sinn
ist auch ein bisschen rettes vom opa von das ist ich glaube das haus im kern ist über
100 jahre alt oder 150 uralt ist aber halt dementsprechend massiv haben das nur renoviert
und ein paar neue sachen gelegt also also wirklich für neubauten weiß ich nicht und ich habe
auch mit der smart home geschichte erst angefangen als wir schon eins zwei jahre hier gewohnt
haben das heißt ich habe nix neu gelegt man muss dazu sagen wenn man die sachen selbst
macht es ist mehr gebastelt es ist mehr verwaltungs overhead also du musst dich da auch ab und
zu mal drum kümmern sei es firmen update sei es home assistant dashboard updates irgendwas
wenn du was neues machen willst und auch die lernkurve ist deutlich höher dafür kannst
du es komplett custom isen wie du willst oder es ist im endeffekt auch billiger wobei
die frage ist ob es so viel billiger ist wenn du deine ganze arbeitszeit noch mit rein rechnest
das weiß ich nicht für mich kommt nur selbst machen in frage was das angeht
also für mich kommt nur selbst machen in frage
was auf jeden fall praktisch ist wo ich mich ärgere dass wir es nicht an mehr stellen haben
sind kabelkanäle also ich würde nach möglichkeit überall wo es möglich ist und eh aufgeschraubt
wird kabelkanäle legen also rohre leerrohre nicht kabelkanäle leerrohre das einzige leerrohr
was ich hier habe ist eine verbindung vom dach bis in keller im flur durch die wand durch also ich
kann ein bisschen was machen aber ich hätte mehr leerrohre legen sollen
das ist ultra teuer das das zeug
das hat alles seine vornachtheit das kann man so pauschal echt nicht sagen
aber für mich kommt nur selbst machen in frage
zumindest eine sache wie gesagt ich würde leerrohre mehr leerrohre legen und wenn
du die chance hast auch gleich überall hin ob du es brauchst oder nicht netzwerkkabel nach
möglichkeit und mehr steckdosen als zu wenige steckdosen das ist auch so was wo ich mich im
nach im nachhinein ein bisschen ärgere ich hätte viel mehr steckdosen im flur und in den einzelnen
zimmern anbringen sollen ich meine die zimmer haben schon ordentlich steckdosen aber das hätten
durchaus noch mal doppelt so viele sein können so nach dem motto einfach acht stück anstatt vier
stück in der ecke und auch an mehr stellen also mehr steckdosen leerrohre und netzwerkkabel
ja das sind die sachen die ich hätte die ich jetzt anders gemacht hätte
und im flur noch eine steckdose anstatt nur eine ich habe bei mir oben im flur an der einen
seite an der anderen seite eine steckdose das müsste das müssten viel mehr sein eigentlich
was die haben die leerrohre versiegelt das sagt ich weiß nicht ob man steckdosen ob man
steckdosen gut erweitern kann ich kann mich damit nicht aus glaubt ihr das jetzt einfach mal ich
kann mich damit null aus zumindest selbst machen können ich sehen ich muss auf jeden fall irgendeinen
typ holen der das macht und dann muss man das ja es ist bisschen eklig wir kommen jetzt mal
kurz fertig was da hier eigentlich vor hat der will uns doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen dass der
wirklich aber wenn das hier ist der neue switch ich habe mich verguckt wollte ich sagen dann
würde ich euch ernsthaft erzählen dass das hier alles 10 gigabit geräte sind also also großartig
was dran kommt an die steckdose nicht also mal so zum beispiel was bei mir an der steckdose im
flur aktuell dran ist es ist ein tablet dran an der an der an der ein steckdose und an der anderen
steckdose ist ein prunden dran für die katze der wasser pumpt also alles nix großartiges
verbrauchsmäßig und ich hätte beispielsweise noch gerne ein zwei steckdosen an der wand für
aber auch sachen die nicht viel brauchen
super hast du voll gelohnt ich darf nicht sagen ich habe mir auch ein 10g switch gekauft ohne
viel 10g geräte zu haben aber der will echt wissen der hat sich in 24 an 28 port an 28
port port 10g switch gekauft und er hat ganze zwei geräte mit 10g karten überhaupt wir reden
hier nicht von dass diese geräte 10 gigabit wirklich ausnutzen können der hat einfach geräte der
theoretisch die möglichkeit hätten 10g links aufzubauen das ist schon ordentlich
xr worker muss man da auf irgendwas achten also mal außer sicherung raus machen
ne aber im moment die steckdosen die die das geht doch gar nicht oder weil ich mein mal gucken
ich suche mir mal ein bild von der steckdose im flur jetzt so so gehen wir jetzt mal von aus hier
so da steckdose die da muss da muss ich noch noch in die wand machen oder weil die steckdose ist
ja in der wand ich will kein loch in die wand machen mit einem steckdosen bohrer kann man sich
sowas bei amazon kaufen sowas da braucht man da also ich glaube da komme ich mit meinem 12 watt
akkuschlagschrauber nicht sonderlich weit oder 12 volt oder oder oder fräst das gut also ich
habe hier so einen gr so ein ding so ein glaube ich glaube sowas habe ich so ein habe ich auch
das set kommt mir sehr bekannt vor ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube den so ungefähr was in
der richtung ich gehe davon aus die wände sind ziemlich massiv ja
ne ne ich baue ich ich werde keine löscher in die wand bohren garantiert nicht das lasst
dann lasse ich lieber dann lasse ich lieber die mal ein paar elektriker hier anrücken die die
am besten die die das auch gemacht haben war das letzte mal und da sollen die mir das einfach
machen ich meine das kostet dann ein bisschen mehr aber dafür ist es dann auch ordentlich
gemacht ich mache das nicht selbst das kostet keine 1000 euro
also ich bin ja ich bin ja den bastel nicht abgeneigt aber alles mit 230 volt
wird bastel ich ungerne ich weiß ich habe gestern steckdosen geflasht aber das ist was
anderes das den kommt ja wieder wieder zugemacht ich fände es mal interessant zu wissen was der
chat so beruflich macht fragt der kerl ich weiß dass wir hier alles mögliche haben wir haben alles
möglich ist es schreiben wir manchmal also wir haben hier relativ viele programmierer und it
leute bestimmt auch ein paar elektrik leute ich weiß dass wir dass wir krankenpfleger haben und
alles mögliche alles mögliche am start natürlich alle ein bisschen mit denke ich mal ein bisschen
mit technik interesse aber programmierer monka es
konsultant technischer produktdesigner ist denn irgendjemand von euch auch a child scrum master
so die richtig guten sachen haben wir ja auch ein a child scrum master
he doesn't know he likes critical information
du warst mal ein product order ne ne ne unter scrum master geht hier nix
du vertreten sein wenn im urlaub ist ok ok cute chat aber sowas von
kuse sagt die polizei ist hier was warum das dann
jetzt kommt raus du hast knossi gesquattet gesquattet der gottbaba hat drei monate abonniert
dankeschön für den sub excellent subscription
scrum master hat wenig zu sagen als product owner ja aber scrum master ist agile und
agile ist das beste
bei uns macht der a child scrum master einfach nix außer ja das machen scrum master die nicht
wissen was sie machen also ein bisschen den überblick bald sich verkehrt aber ganz ehrlich
ein guter scrum master muss auch gar nicht viel machen wenn die leute taugen dabei
gibt es auch jeder kann agile sein alles sind sie agile
heute ist alles super agil und flexibel dynamisch
tribe lead und tribe manager excellent jetzt geht es los hier
ich weiß mit ach und krach noch was was tribe was ein tribe ist das ist ein tribe ist wenn
ich das richtig zusammen kriege wenn man mehrere agile teams hat pass mal auf max max stonks
business talk wenn man mehrere agile teams hat und wenn jetzt beispielsweise programmierer 1 aus
dem ersten team und programmierer 2 aus dem zweiten team miteinander reden dann ist das
quasi tribes die sich vernetzt haben total total hängen geblieben letztendlich aber man nennt
das so und es ist halt ganz toll und agil
wenn das wenn das jetzt richtig war
kennst du auch klaren nur in cs
agil twitch chat aber sowas von ok mal kurz fertig gucken es bringt ihm überhaupt nix er
findet sich so geil mit dem also es ist ein geiles hart geile stück hardware was andere
frage noch mal thema wedern habe in meiner wohnung gerade keine möglichkeit auf land
zurückzugreifen da mietwohnung zum beispiel mietwohnung und so weiter bin bei wo davon habe
400k der router macht über wlan circa 300k aber fällt oft aus haben wir dann ein netge router
gekauft den net ok ja
vielleicht nicht 5g 5g klappt meistens ein bisschen schneller muss gucken dass sie auch
über 5g über den 5g channel da wie heißt 5g frequenz dings da wenn du die ssid hast
auf 4g und auf 2,4 gigahertz und auf stimmt nicht 5g auf 2,4 gigahertz oder auf 5 gigahertz
musst du gucken dass du die richtige nimmst mit mit 5 gigahertz manchmal ist das ein
bisschen schwierig zu erkennen je nach endgerät mit 5 gigahertz verbunden dann habe ich keine
ahnung was das für schmerzen hat vielleicht ein bisschen an den antennen umdrehen kann
ich kann man kann alle möglichen kannst mal den channel du kannst mein channel wechseln
kannst man die channel durch durch probieren ob es irgendwie besser wird wenn die nachbarn
da viel haben kann das sein das ist übrigens eine coole sache an wifi 6 dass sie das automatisch
aushandeln können mit channel das ist eine richtig coole geschichte dann kannst du noch
ein bisschen rumstellen je nachdem ob der access point ist erlaubt quasi wie breit
die die channels sind und sowas kann man ein bisschen rumprobieren aber dass du da jetzt
von 200k wenn du direkt daneben stehst und dass jetzt statt 200k auf einmal 400k durch
kriegst ist recht unwahrscheinlich zumal man halt sagen muss generell das ist ja schon
ist ja schon recht recht ordentlich ja also 200mbit wlan ist schon nicht verkehrt
das ist schon das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht man darf sich ja nicht so über nicht so nicht
so von die die schreiben jetzt ja wifi 6 wie viel geht das über wifi 6 1,8 gigabit oder
so angeblich das ist alles nur theoretisch das wirst du in der praxis nirgendswo erleben
einfach mal ein iperf anschmeißen und gucken was drüber geht sollte ich spiel pr3 a
aktivieren in meiner fritzbox ja wenn es deine endgeräte können warum nicht also es kann
auf jeden fall nichts schaden man kann es überhaupt nicht vergleichen man weiß nicht
wie laut es ist wie weit man weg ist das kann man nicht vergleichen das ist deswegen habe
ich ja in meinem serverraum video habe ich mir gedacht wir machen mal eine big brain
aktion und zwar als ich das damals gezeigt habe habe ich da so nen so nen lautstärke
messgerät in die ecke gelegt und habs irgendwo im video gezeigt ich finde es jetzt kann
ich so ein lautstärke messgerät in die ecke gelegt und da konnte man dann wirklich gut
erkennen was das gerade für eine lautstärke hat aber irgendwie finde ich es gerade im
video wo ich das mache ist auch egal es war relativ leise weil ansonsten ist immer schwierig
anhand vom rauschen was die kamera aufnimmt zu hören wie laut jetzt der server ist kann
ich bei einer fritzbox als router einen tp link router als mesh verwenden ich habe keinen
flassen schimmer okay so now we have a baseline let's plug in this switch and see if it is
noticeably louder than the rest of the stuff running in my server rack ja moment warte
mal ab erst mal abwarten bis das ding richtig gebootet ist viele viele geräte machen erst
mal wupp werden leise und dann pusten sie noch mal zwei minuten bis sie bis die lüfter
regelung greift und außerdem schließt erst mal was an das ist jetzt nicht gerade sondern
ich aussahre kräftig außerdem ist das übrigens nicht so wie lautstärke funktioniert also
wenn du ein gerät nimmst was eine gewisse lautstärke hat oder nimmst ein zweites gerät
was eine gewisse was die gleiche lautstärke alleine hat und du machst die zusammen an
dann sind die lauter als eins zusammen also genau funktioniert das nicht mit dem ja das
gibt einen speedtest docker warum braucht man einen speedtest docker super anonymer speedtest
dann es hat gesucht mit 10g das gibt wie testest du intern am einfachsten netzwerk speed damit
allerdings ist wenn man sich das für windows runter lädt die hatten da richtig viele bugs
drinnen das da das ist auch gut die zwei sachen das reicht in der regel am besten man testet
von linux zu linux die windows sachen bei iperf ist ein bisschen schwammig manchmal
liebre speed what the fuck es gibt ein docker speedtest das muss ich jetzt gleich mal ausprobieren
gibt echt gibt's einen docker speedtest what the fuck okay und welcher davon jetzt
der da der da adolf intel was na der adolf intel liebre speed hier das ist fast zum teufel
ist liebre speed auch hier das probieren wir jetzt mal aus also muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren
okay wir installieren wir gehen mal in die vm ich muss muss man gerade mal einen eigenen
speedtest installieren und dann muss ich was essen ich habe übelst hunger
das ist einfach webserver mit dem hier ich starte es jetzt noch mal das probieren wir
jetzt mal aus aber der adolf intel gut der kann ja auch nichts dafür dass der name schon
so negativ vorbelastet ist bestell pizza und bleib on
also wo haben wir es hier muss man da etwas spezielles angeben oder so oder einfach nur
oder einfach nur starten adolf intel speed das ist ja auch ein repo oder so ich starte
den jetzt einfach nur und guck dass es funktioniert gibt es ja keine gibt es ja keine extra was
wie wir gegen das docker run ein einmalig die dm na und dann dings und name name check
wehe da ist ja keine anleitung dazu was man braucht
okay erst mal das ganze internet runterladen excellent
geht nicht muss man das priviledge starten vielleicht
muss man das irgendwie priviledge starten aber das sollte eigentlich dazu dastehen
ja ja keine ahnung was der verschmerzen hat docker run
ja docker run name speedtest ah hier ports muss man angeben ansonsten macht es eigentlich
kein ansonsten habe ich so richtig gemacht ich ja na ja normalerweise muss man die ports
nicht angeben der nimmt in die fall port wenn das als expose drin steht muss man vielleicht
als als gut laufen lassen der chat ist nicht todier dann weiß ich nicht was der für schmerzen
hat wie stelle ich startet man um an privileged container so
docker ps ja das war es gut habe gerade eine diskussion kann man selber einen discord server
hosten du kannst es gibt habe ich letztens auf github gesehen es gibt welche die haben
versucht irgendwie die die discord api nachzubauen mit so eigenem kram aber ich glaube nicht
dass das auch ansatzweise nur so gut funktioniert wie discord ich glaube da hast du keine guten
chancen du kannst ein teamspeak selbst hosten jetzt geht's exzellent aber marie budet alles
klar port 80 jetzt gucken wir uns mal mein speedtest an
localhost 80 bam liebre speed da sind wir test ja gut es geht übers loopback interface
da da flutscht's was jetzt halt überhaupt nichts bringt weil das nur intern ist
also ich habe von meiner vm auf meine vm habe ich einen speed von so viel okay das ist reichlich
unsinnig zu wissen ehrlich gesagt so wie sieht es von meiner windows kiste aus dahin start
warum ist der upload besser weil der inter glaube ich der misst einfach nicht richtig
von von intern übers loopback aufs loopback ich guck jetzt ist besser das vorher war ja
von der vm auf die vm das ist übers loopback das hat den verwirrt ja also ich krieg einen
gigabit zwischen zwischen den zwei rechnern okay passt ja auch ist ja auch gigabit netzwerk
ja okay jetzt habe ich liebre speed ich weiß zwar nicht was ich mit liebre speed mache
aber ich habe liebre speed hat man mal wieder was gelernt in dem video dass es sowas gibt
aber mal ganz davon abgesehen wenn man firefox ist das problem wirklich probieren wir mal
aber ist es nicht sinnvoller also ich kann einfach iperf oder sowas nehmen anstatt das
wahrscheinlich ist das hier eher geeignet für leute die kein bock haben auf kommandozeile
firefox ist langsamer okay firefox upload lieber
was auch immer chat ich mach das jetzt erstmal aus hallo abbrechen please docker ps der will
ich abbrechen docker stop stop stop docker geh aus weg mit dir docker weg erst mal ist
erst mal das image wieder runter schmeißen images sind ja weg 400 mb so ein speedtest
sehr fast wie eine elektronen anwendung ram verbraucht adolf aus genau ja so chat schön
dass ihr dabei gewesen seid ich gehe jetzt was essen ich habe mega hunger vielleicht
machen wir heute abend bin dann nämlich äußerst gespannt drauf oder von ausreden bin dann
nämlich äußerst gespannt drauf vielleicht probieren wir heute abend noch esx auf dem
raspberry pi aus doch setke ist aktiviert du musst refreshen ich habe es vorhin aktiviert
dauert aber ein bisschen bis es gesüngt ist wahrscheinlich setke ist aktiviert ja es
gibt jetzt seit ein paar tagen habe ich gelesen gibt es wohl einen testbild für esx auf raspberry
pi windows au excellent windows update was möchte es denn eigentlich von mir haben das
und kumulativ update for windows 10 version 2004 aha sehr schön windows wer will sowas
ich will das ausprobieren betreiben will ich das auch nicht aber ich fände es geil
wenn es geht das hätte einen vorteil doch es hätte wirklich einen vorteil für alle
die ein bisschen rumspielen wollen und üben wollen mit dem esx weil das ist schon an einigen
stellen nicht so selbst erklärt ich bin ja auch jetzt nicht der große esx profi ok leute
schön dass ihr dabei gewesen seit ich gehe jetzt essen ich habe hunger vielleicht sehen
wir uns heute abend wenn ich morgen mit dann probieren wir das aus esx auf dem pi gutes
tool zur plusbühne allhuse ich kenne mich im windows eh nicht aus wir gucken jetzt mal
kurz ob der friseur vielleicht streamt dann hausten wir den nein macht er nicht ob der
m core streamt dann hausten wir ihn falsche m core der da den da meine ich das streamt
auch was hat denn der m core führen in twitch account jeder ist nicht bent habe den gestern
noch gesehen drei ach war das vorher echt der richtige quatsch ja was hat der m core
der heißt bestimmt nicht der heißt bestimmt ja auch german elita amiel ich habe ich kann
ich habe den gestern erst noch zugeguckt beim stream so hat er sein sein channel vielleicht
verlinkt about twitch facebook instagram ich habe keine ahnung wo er hin ist ach das ist
er ach der hat vorher wirklich gesagt ich habe gar nicht gecheckt dass er das war lull
warum heißt er denn m core hier haben ich gestern noch zugeguckt ja danke für den sub
vorhin ich habe es gar nicht mitgekriegt dass du das bist hat mich sogar gehostet poggers
okay keiner da den hausten kann dann sehen wir uns morgen ich gehe futtern oder heute
Abend bis denn machts gut chat wir sehen uns